Õpetaja: Näed, väga Uhke. Ee, ühesõnaga. Ma teen siia ühe komeiti. Kas kellegil on vaja järgi tulla? Ega siin midagi väga Eriti ei ole tehtud, aga sellegipoolest
Õpetaja: globaalseks.
Õpetaja: Võibolla oleks aeg ruttu see skill ära teha.
Õpetaja: See, et saate järgi tulla. Ee, ma saaksin tegelikult selle ise ka ära taustal teha. Aga võibolla veel õppimise mõttes on ikkagi hea vaadata, kuidas keili luua. Jah, ei, kas te on pärast pausi ajal või?
Õpetaja: Või teeme koos
Õpetaja: Ee otseselt. Tegelikult ei ole isegi pluginat vaja tõmmata. Aga see plugin annab ee, paar head asja.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui. Kas teil on see, Kas teil? On siin siukene julla üleval või ei ole?
Õpetaja: Oota, ma pean. Korra. Ma pean korra panema Power tools I tagasi sisse. Mul on Power Toys Vabandust,
Õpetaja: mul ei ole see highlight Imine Praegult aktiivne.
Õpetaja: Fokusseeri asi.
Õpetaja: See ei tule veel mõtleb,
Õpetaja: No nüüd on nii. Ee, näete seda? Kas teil on selline niiöelda Cloud I logo? Ee, siis see ei ole primaarne praegu seda saada Aga pikas perspektiivis? Lihtsalt Siis plugins
Õpetaja: seal. Te saate juba varsti ise ära õppida ja Market Place is Lihtsalt kirjutada Cloude
Õpetaja: ja siis see asi siin ära installida. Ta nõuab mingit restarti ka
Õpetaja: ja näete. Siin all on Niukene. Asi, Vaata et File Reference Shortcuts
Õpetaja: ta peaks olema võimeline niimoodi et K. Ja kui sa oled highlightinud kuskil koodist mingid read, siis ta lihtsalt Chat I viskab. Ee, nagu et see fail See rida. Vaata sellest. Sa räägid, et millest ma räägin? Ma näitan, et see on nagu see, et oletame, et mul on mingisugune Beef Selle templetiga.
Õpetaja: Ma võtan Control ilt ka. Kuid terminal ei ole juba lahti. Ja vähemalt sellises režiimis, et ta ära tunneks,
Õpetaja: siis ta hüppab niimoodi siit lahti näete, Cloud Code.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma praegu teen uuesti seda ka, siis peaks tulema. Näete, kuidas ta tegi? Ta räägib, et Aa, see see fail line. Üks kuni üheksa on siin kuni üks kuni üheksa. Et edaspidi saab niimoodi veits suhelda. Ja see teine osa on See et isegi kui ma ei taha seda siia niimoodi selle shortcut seda rada siia panna,
Õpetaja: siis kui ma selle ära Selectin vaata, Onju, Siis ma saan talle öelda, nagu ta taval ei saa aru, et ma suhtlen Sellest
Õpetaja: saad öelda lihtsalt näiteks Selected
Õpetaja: ja siis nagu Räägid, et. Oot, mis mul siin on? Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. Et ee, siis Tal on see idea integreeritud. Juhul, kui see ei tööta. Seal on veel üks konks. Ka. Mõtlen, et me ei hakka praegu seadistama. Kõik me tehke palun seda. Nagu Proovige ise saada. Korda Ee, kui te panete kaldkriips ja ide
Õpetaja: integration on show status
Õpetaja: siis pead saama valida Intelligence idea Kui Niukene tikk on, taga. Siis ta juba saab aru. Vaata, et see töötab. Kuidas te saate aru? Niikuinii ongi see, et kui te vaitate lihtsalt seda
Õpetaja: Ultra Light ka, et Valid mingi teksti
Õpetaja: siis, kui Cloud Code avaneb, siis ee siis seda seda kasutada. Tal on nagu Connection,
Õpetaja: et nad on omavahel ühendatud, see On nagu peamine pluss, mis Mul on. Vanasti Ma vajutasin lihtsalt siia. Vaata, et avada nagu seda terminali. Ega ta töötab ja vahel ta ei tööta.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd ma lihtsalt avastasin, et kui tahaks justkui seda fetruuri. Muidu on niimoodi, et sul on mingi chat juba pooleli on Ju
Õpetaja: sul on mingisugune chat juba pooleli
Õpetaja: ka. Ta teeb uue terminali akna lahti, et ainult sellega on see nagu kuidagi see Connection, see Selleks,
Õpetaja: ee, et seda pluginat võib siis ka endale installida. Näed, siin näitab ka midagi. Ikkagi üheksa üheksa lain. See kuidagi ajas muutub
Õpetaja: vist Mitte alles siis, kui midagi vajutad.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: ee, asi, mis tegelikult. Noh, veel tuleb. Tegelikult üks restart niikuinii ära, nii et võime siis kasutada seda võimalust teki korra Slack lahti.
Õpetaja: Ja kuidas, Aa, kolistate Natukene ringi
Õpetaja: teil on? See on üks niukene. See on mingi reedesessionis.
Õpetaja: Tõmmake see alla mingi lihtsalt selle Cloud I peale ja vajaksin download.
Õpetaja: Pange kuskile downloads kausta või kuhu iganes. Teil on seda lihtne üles leida.
Õpetaja: Ma Võin ise seda ka teha. Täpselt ma peangi tegema. Mul endal vist ka pole, et kui Download Id alla saad, vaadata ka open containing Folder, et kuhu ta paneb? Selle Minul? Ta paneb igal juhul C ketas. Näete see. Noh, see üks on, see, et mul on see kasutusarvem olnud.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd, mis on vaja teha, on see, et. Ee, mul on te mõned enda templateid
Õpetaja: Mis asi on Live template on See, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ee, Life template on siis selline. Ee, sisse ehitatud. Ee, kui sa hakkad paari tähte kirjutama, näiteks jaamas, kirjutad tähed, main,
Õpetaja: Siis ta teeb meetodi sellise meetodid, mida on võimalik nagu siis koodis käivitada.
Õpetaja: Kirjutad sinna sõna, näiteks kuskil Mingi foor teeb voor tsükli, ta Teeb nagu põhja. Hästi, kiirelt. Ära vaata senikaua, kuni sina kirjutad sinna paar tähemärki. Vaata, mis on nagu siis tema teeb lihtsalt mingisuguse templeti,
Õpetaja: Mina olen teinud ka siia mõned I, et elu oleks nagu natukene mugavam ja kohe neid ei kasuta, aga. Aga suht suht varsti kohe juba kasutame. Mis? Te peate tegema, et neid asju nagu endale sisse saada. See on ka enda nagu see sama, mis te tegite alguses, Setup Iga te, ee, importisite mingisuguseid setting. Uid.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis te tahate teha? Siis vajutate hamburgeri menüüle
Õpetaja: ja siin on ja import settings klikkige Seda
Õpetaja: peale seda otsingi ülesse see kaust.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma annan teistele võimalustele vaadata. Otsige ülesse see kaust. Ee, see sama sifail seda lahti pakkima ei pea.
Õpetaja: Valige see sip fail
Õpetaja: ja siis peaks importimisel juba näitama, et Üritad. Mingeid templeid, et siis importida ära. No teen, mina ka seda
Õpetaja: väikene häkk teile. Palju, Davai Näiteks Praegu ta topib kuhugi. Jumal teab, kuhu kausta
Õpetaja: mul on. Mina teen niimoodi pidevalt et kui mul on. Avan mingisuguse asja, mida ma otsin. Aga kui mul on kuidagi lihtsam neid juba kuskilt siit ee, mujalt üles otsida, Näiteks, ee, ma Ei tea, Download või mis iganes kaust. Te võite alati teha niimoodi et tavalises niiöelda Browserist lihtsalt kopite selle raja.
Õpetaja: Ee, see aken, mis on juba lahti. Mis tahab midagi avada. Kui tulete siia ülesse, vajutate Enter, siis ta läheb kohe sinna kausta. No praegu oleks nii lihtne Ma oleks saanud siit samast kõrvalt ka selle download kausta üles leida. Aga vahel, kui on tegemist, Noh, sa oled kuskil pannud mingisugused failid Või asjad nad asuvad. Kus Jumal teab, Sul on mingi enda shortcut või? See on juba sul kuskil lahti, siis sa saad alati seda teha. Nagu
Õpetaja: lõppeesmärk on, on valida see fail
Õpetaja: Ja siis tuleb ette mingi niukene. Väikene aken.
Õpetaja: Kas soovid ee, importida sisse Live templateid, selle Ekspordi ajal midagi muud ei olegi.
Õpetaja: Te saate tegelikult tervest oma sellest intelligest teha. Ekspordi. Vaata kõik oma lemmikud settingud aga te saate valida nagu, et mida Nagu te tahate, et seal setting uta. Niiöelda ekspordis on sees olemas, et mis asju te saate, tahate endale alles hoida, Vajutate Okei,
Õpetaja: ja peale seda siis ee, Important restart. Teeme siis selle ära. Vaata, et seda niikuinii on vaja Kohe varsti
Õpetaja: samal ajal, kui Ta seda teeb siis. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, Mina rääkisin eelmine nädal, et selle voe ja ka tegelikult need teised. Niiöelda reaktiivsed tehnoloogiad, et seal on
Õpetaja: Aa, andmete mõttes. Seal on üks väga oluline Ee, põhimõte andmete voolavuse osas.
Õpetaja: Keegi tuleb meelde, millest ma räägin,
Õpetaja: et seal on üks asja, Suur nihukene põhimõte ja on
Õpetaja: andmed voolavad ülevaate alla, Mis tähendab ülevaate alla, on see, et kui meil hakkavad olema nagu komponendid, meil on Vaade
Õpetaja: meil on vaadanud, mis on peamine komponent Juba Sea see reaktiivselt. Laeb. Vaata tegelikult Vaata, Urli Kaudu on ju, et kui me hakkame kasutama niukseid, erinevaid faile ja klotsikesi. Kus sees on erinevad Html osad siis tegelikult andmed. Tegelikult on ikkagi kuskilt sealt üleval vaates, näiteks ja hakkavad kuidagi alla Niimoodi, Flowma.
Õpetaja: Nüüd üldse, siis see plokkide mäng. Ee oli ka, et mis on siin hästi tähtis. Ee, kontseptsioon, millest, aru saada. Ma panen korra veel selle pildi. Seni ka nüüd. See restart on kõigil tehtud.
Õpetaja: Ee, pildid.
Õpetaja: See pilt. Põhimõtteliselt, et meil on kaks poolt. Meil on visuaalne pool. Mis on template blokis
Õpetaja: template tagide vahel? Ee, meil tuleb põhimõtteliselt siis Niukene all. Niukene Blokk kus on meetodite Blokk
Õpetaja: ja arusaamine. See, et kogu aeg, kui me omavahel nüüd hakkame suhtlema, need kaks poolt omavahel, ei saa otse Connect Ida,
Õpetaja: me ei Saa lihtsalt meetodis öelda. Lihtsalt, et näita seda ja seda rivi Ja või. Või ma ei tea näita seda Varja seda, mida iganes, vaata, Me ei saa selles funktsionaalses Me ei saa selles Javascripti koodis öelda, et et millisena Ta peab seda visuaalset osa niiöelda kuvama,
Õpetaja: vaid meie Suhtlus omavahel käib kogu aeg läbi. Andmebloki Muutujate läbi andmete.
Õpetaja: Ma saan öelda üleval, et. Hei, kui siin massiivis on, Näiteks tabelis, Vaata, on Headerid Eesti perekonnanimi vanus. Näiteks Niuke Tabel on üleval ja saame öelda. Vaata, et ainult siis on Point joonistada siia neid ridu
Õpetaja: kui Datablokis on näiteks ee, meil Niukene
Õpetaja: muutujana Nagu, ee. Ma ei tea, Customers.
Õpetaja: Seal on Niukene massiiv
Õpetaja: ja me saame öelda, nagu seal üleval ee Me saame öelda selles visuaalses blokis nagu Niukene. Näita seda neid või joonista need või tee see Html Road.
Õpetaja: Ainult siis, kui siin sees on midagi. Vaata, on ju siis vastavalt sellele. Ta joonistab, et see suhtlus hakkab Käima. Meil läbi andmete.
Õpetaja: Kas sa tahad midagi kuvada üleval või mitte, see kuvamine tuleb otsustada andmete pealt. Me programmeerime neid asju niimoodi, et asju visuaalselt kuvatakse. Andmete pealt kuvatakse, ei kuvata
Õpetaja: ja samamoodi Kui keegi lihtsalt visuaalis on, sul mingi vorm,
Õpetaja: kus kasutaja täidab mingid väljad ära.
Õpetaja: Meie eesmärk on käivitada see et saada andmed Back ee, Back Endi
Õpetaja: siis Kuidas me saame sealt visuaalist kokku? Me ei programmeeri niimoodi, et Kuule, seal üleval on mingid kastikesed. Ole nüüd, nunnu, mine Võta sealt väljalt sisu ja sealt väljalt sisu. Ja siis saada need kuskile. Ei, meil on see visuaalne pool seotud tegelikult siis niukeste reaktiivsete Ee, muutujatega. Ja me saame siis koodis öelda. Lihtsalt kurat, anna mulle selle
Õpetaja: muud sisu. Vaata, Ja see on see, mida ma tahan Back In le saata, et see kogu suhtlus hakkab käima läbi
Õpetaja: data.
Õpetaja: Et Need, kaks asja omavahel saavad kokku ja üldse moodustavad terviku läbi selle
Õpetaja: See alguses on natukene Niukene segane teema.
Õpetaja: Aa, mis? Mis mõttes? Vaata, onju? Ja alguses, kui ma igast hakkan küsima, üks küsimus me siin Teeme või nii edasi. Ja te unustate kogu aeg nagu. Ära vaata, et need kaks maailma omavahel saavad ainult põhimõtteliselt suhelda Ee, and läbi andmete.
Õpetaja: No idee järgi on võimalik otseselt näppida ka ee niiöelda Html elemente otse läbi referentside. Aga me tegelikult seda ei taha teha,
Õpetaja: See On nagu see on your resping For Trouble nagu aa. Pigem sellepärast, milles on, kui ma programmiliselt tahan katsuda justkui nagu mingit Html elementi
Õpetaja: mingisugust Html i koodi, siis eeldus on see, et kui ma viitan sellele elemendile, siis see päriselt peab seal olemas olema nagu renderdatud kujul lõplikus versioonis. Kui ma viitan mingisugusele
Õpetaja: või mis iganes, vaatame elemendile, mida hetkel veel ei ole rendeldatud. Sellepärast seal pole nagu vastavaid Condition Eid Ee, siis tekivad vead.
Õpetaja: Sa viitad mingisugusele asjale mida veel? Hetkel ei ole veel olemas. Nagu, võibolla kohe natukene hiljem. Ta on olemas mingil Põhjusel on ju? Aga. Aga kui me ehitame kogu oma flow ilusti, ainult andmete peale, siis on väga lihtne. Kõik toimib. Kõik joonistatakse siis Vastavalt andmetele,
Õpetaja: kui andmed nii ütlevad, siis nii asi joonistatakse. Kui ei, siis ei joonistata ja siis ei teki mingisugust programmivigu, et me kuidagi Viitame mingitele asjadele, mida pole olemas. Ee, jaavas võiks tuua seda näidet Null Point Receptionist. No ma toon näite. Meil on objekt student
Õpetaja: studenti Sees on ee, väljad. First name ja last name.
Õpetaja: Kui mul on üks muutuja. Ee, see muutuja. Näiteks student
Õpetaja: Kui mul on seal taga sellest student objektist. Niiöelda siis. Noh, student. Objekt on päriselt seal muutuja taga Kuidas ma saaks First Name i näiteks kätte,
Õpetaja: kui mul on Mingisugune student objekt. Mul on First name. Kuidas? Ei, sellepärast praegu. Sa puutusid otse välja, Vaata aga, jaavas on need väljad. Objekti väljad on Private, sa ei saa otse viidata. See on see, mis sa paned punkt ja tahtsid öelda First Name viitaks otse objektile objekti Väljale kuidas Saab
Õpetaja: kuidas?
Õpetaja: Jah, Get First Name. Meil on public meetodid. Põhimõtteliselt, mis saavad selle objekti sees toimetada selle väljaväärtuse saada. Aga Point on nüüd See, ee, et kui sa ütled punkt Get First Name, see tähendab seda, et sa soovid käivitada meetodit, mis on seotud konkreetse objektiga,
Õpetaja: Aga Kui selle, Ob. Kui seal selle muutuja taga päriselt objekti pole. Mäletate, ma juba hakkasin endale varakult jahuma sellest. Vaata, et, ee, see asi, Muutuja.
Õpetaja: See muutuja on sildikene, on ju? Aga objekt, mida külje, mis on talle külge? Pandud, on kaks erinevat asja.
Õpetaja: Noh, kujutame ette. Vaata, Kui mul on silt. Nagu näiteks. Ma ei tea, Person. Näiteks onju? Kui see oleks minu Kui mul on küljes ja keegi ütleb Person, X, Vaata, ole hea. Ee Person X, Ulata mulle. Ma ei tea, see telefon
Õpetaja: siis siin. On objekt taga. Vaata, kes saab, Niimoodi, Palun, Meil on lihtsalt see silt.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt silt. Kujutage ette, silt on aga objekti ei. Ole ja nüüd, ütlete. Börs on X. Palun, olete mulle telefon.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: ei, ei saa vist väga aega, on ju? Ei saa keegi tühjust. Vot see on null Point a reception. See tähendab seda, et objekti polegi. Aga muutuja on. Vot selline asi tekitab jaavas. Meil null Point Reception I. Üritame käivitada mingisugust
Õpetaja: tegevust
Õpetaja: objektiga, mida ei ole võimalik seda teha, sest et objekti pole. See on nagu programmi. See on nagu programmeerimis viga. Selline olukord ongi see, et sa oled programmis, kirjutad? Palun ulata mulle telefon. Aga sa ei ole seda programmeerinud korrektselt ära, et siin see objekti ei ole. Taga Silt on aga objekti pole.
Õpetaja: See on null. Point Reception. Ja siin Ee. Frontis on põhimõtteliselt samamoodi. Näiteks, et kui me, kui me kasutaksime, siin, on sisse ehitatud Siuke võimalus, et sa saad ka tegelikult ee programmiliselt viidata konkreetsetele Html elementidele, mis templite osas on?
Õpetaja: Aga its Asking for trouble, sellepärast, et Niipea, kui sa näiteks pöördud nende poole asju, mida veel hetkel nagu ei ole olemas, ei ole rendeldatud või pole vastavaid tingimusi, see on Programmeerimisviga Jälle siis tulevad jamad.
Õpetaja: Aga vot nüüd ongi Niimoodi Selles ongi see hea konks. Vot see React
Õpetaja: see mis on Facebooki vennad? Metavennad tegid niiöelda, onju, React,
Õpetaja: et nad tegid lihtsalt selles mõttes raamistiku, mis reageerib andmete peale ja siis on lihtne,
Õpetaja: siis kuvatakse vastavalt neid andmetele asju. Või kui neid pole. See ei kuvata, aga kõik toimib kui nõiaväel ise. Sellepärast lihtsalt andmete flow pealt. Ee, otsustatakse, mida kasutajal on vaja näidata või mitte,
Õpetaja: et muidugi see minu jaoks segane. Miks niimoodi. Aga nüüd? Ma saan täielikult aru nagu. Sest see on nagu geniaalne, See on täiesti geniaalne lähenemine. Kuidas asju teha,
Õpetaja: et vältida seda, et me ei hakka viitama asjadele, mida pole olemas, kui mõttes on andmed, siis on. Kui ei ole, siis ei ole. Mis ei tähenda, et me nüüd ei saa kirjutada halba koodi, kus mingisugused jamad hakkavad tekkima,
Õpetaja: Kui sa ikkagi oled seal mingeid asju programmeerinud ja mõelnud nagu läbi et kasutaja peaks nägema ja andmed on, aga kui andmeid ei ole Ja kasutaja ei näe, siis see on ikka tema jaoks jama, onju? Mingit vigu ei tule, aga lõpptulemus ei ole ikka õige. Vaata, et Et, Ee, seda me peame tegema
Õpetaja: nii.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, aga hakkamegi siis vaatama seda.
Õpetaja: Ee, mul on bussitud Või tegelt, ma ei tea, ma Tegin komite. Kas bussi tegin? Kontroll ka?
Õpetaja: Nagu kilo näitab. Kas mul on midagi. Push Ida ei ole Push. It on.
Õpetaja: Tahate järgi tulla? Jah, tulge
Õpetaja: Ja senikaua teeks korra taski ka igaks juhuks lahti, et meil on meeles, Mis Me
Õpetaja: Ee, veb. Seitsmes oli mingi päris korralik Action Mäletan, lugesime selle läbi. Seal oli mingi rämedalt staapi, mis hakkab toimuma.
Õpetaja: Ee, teen selle lahti selle Feb seitsme.
Õpetaja: Ee aga siis samal ajal. Ma juba tean siis, mis me tahame siis teha?
Õpetaja: Pangaautomaadid. Ee, kas tegelt Login View vist oli. Mis me päriselt toimetame? Praegu Mäletaks Login View.
Õpetaja: Kas me jõudsime mingi selle vaate Ära ka teha? Jõudsime. Just. See oligi viimane asi.
Õpetaja: Nii, Siin on mingisugune Ee, Nira, Paneme Fronten serveri käima ka. Ee, et vist sai tehtud ka mingi mina. Hästi, kiirelt tegin. Ee, see. Ütlesin, et teile Lihtsalt vaadake. Tegin sinna juba näitlikult ette. Mingi kaks kasti.
Õpetaja: Aa, kasutajanimi Parool on ju? Ja siis nupp, mis lihtsalt tegi. Tere, maailm. Oli, nii, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, no Ma Võtan korra selle lahti ka. Vaatan, kas mul see asi juba tuleb ette.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on sisselogimine. Jutt käib sellest, onju? Ja vajutad Nuppu on Hello World. Ja siin tuligi mul see mõtteharjutus, et vaata, mis on nüüd siis ee, niiöelda visuaalset poolt ja Action It niiöelda Ühendav pool. Need on andmed.
Õpetaja: See oli see, mis te suht kiirelt ära arvasite. Ma andsin liiga palju juba varasemat jahu siin jappisin, Mainisin Kohe, et arvutan ruttu ära. Tavaliselt teistel on ikka rohkem aega läinud, et nuputada ära, et mis on see ühendav lüli visuaalse poole ja Action I vahel
Õpetaja: Andmed. Ühel või teisel viisil on alati andmed. Action. Iga toon andmed ära. Kuvan
Õpetaja: või vastupidi. Näiteks sisestan andmed visuaalsel poolel Action iga. Tahan neid ära saata. Mis on neile ühist andmed? See
Õpetaja: see asi, näiteks Tekstin Lihtsalt, see on ühine
Õpetaja: Ee, Nüüd on natukene rohkem aega, siis Minu mõte on üldse. See template siit. Aa, natukene korda teha. Läheks korra Boots Trap I.
Õpetaja: Ma tahaks otsida niukest, ee, Label, It ja input I, Mis on? Ee, mulle meeldiksid, on see, et on nagu kasti sees natukene nagu see. Vot näe midagi taolist, Näete seda
Õpetaja: aga mitte niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: Floating labels.
Õpetaja: Kas te näete seda siin? Vaata palju
Õpetaja: nii. Ee. Tulge teie ka. Siia
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma siia sain. Ma vist kirjutasin input, vä? Ei, ma kirjutasin label
Õpetaja: ja mitte Ahah. Tegelikult see ongi. Juba. Näete, see sama siin. Vot nii tahan. Näete, et oleks nagu ma kirjutan teksti, siia, siis ta ei kao eest ära. Ta jääb siia ülesse.
Õpetaja: Seal on väga suur vahe, kui ta kaoks. Ära vaata, siis meil label It pole, aga see annab üsna lihtsa nagu ui disaini meile, et me ei pea eraldi label It panema ülesse kõrvale, vasakule paremale. Kui me seda tahame teha, siis nii on Fine, vaata aga, mulle. Selles mõttes meeldib, et ta Niukene Minimalistlik
Õpetaja: siis mis me tahame. Oh, email ja päästevärd. Oh, sobib ju. Võtame kogu selle kupatuse siit niimoodi
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd korra võib selle konteineri osa. Kas ta konteiner on olemas üldse?
Õpetaja: Aa, te otsite minu koodi. Praegu on ju? Võtame selle sama osa, kus meil on ja see selle ühe Tv I tõmbame kokku ja teise Dv. I. Tõmbame kokku. Aa, see Paton võib isegi jääda.
Õpetaja: Ja need nüüd Lihtsalt siis kustutame ära või pastime selle sama uue koodiga.
Õpetaja: Ma lihtsalt tahaks, et oleks ilusad input Id,
Õpetaja: et on üks input siin kulumises
Õpetaja: ja teine form Floating on siis selle asja nimi
Õpetaja: põhimõtteliselt klassist. Vaata, nagu vähemalt on näha,
Õpetaja: mis midagi juhtus siin, Nii et kui te teete oma selle asja lahti, Siis on niuksed kastid. Näete neid?
Õpetaja: No me võime kõik nullist ka teha. Kas teeme nullist korra? Kas tal on raskusi Korraks Teeme nullist.
Õpetaja: Jah, so Then New Birts peavad.
Õpetaja: Kas sa panid ka mingi täiesti uue haru nime, mis? Ei ole juba olemasolev, Aga Clash Iv.
Õpetaja: No kas kui V kaks. Vaata, ma mõtlen, kui sa võtad haru ja sul on enda. Kuidas su nimi oli? Eesnimi
Õpetaja: Karin, kui Sul on juba nagu Karin Feb seitse olemas. Siis sa ei saa.
Õpetaja: Pane lihtsalt sidekriips vee. Kolm lõppu või midagi taolist. Vaata, et ta võiks olla nagu see on see viga. Ega ma ei tea peast. Ee,
Õpetaja: ta ütleb seda, et. Ee. Sinul on selline komitis. Vaata, sinul on praegu siin üks fail, mis on siia tekkinud, On ju, Aga ta ütleb seda. Vaata, esiteks, sa pole öelnud, et kas jälgi või Ära jälgi checkout. I, vaata. Minu arust see on täpselt samasugune fail Olemas Ta ei saagi.
Õpetaja: Sa nüüd üritad teha?
Õpetaja: Ära niimoodi tee. Sul on? No mis siis sinna lõppu panna? See V kaks. Vaatame seitse
Õpetaja: ja. Ja, noh, pärast siis kustutada. Ära vaata, mis praegu Karinil oli. Karin oli selline olukord, et. Ee, tal oli see. Tal oli fail juba seal hetkel olemas. Kui ta tahtis tulla nagu uude kohta,
Õpetaja: aga Tal oli siis selles mõttes Untract, et see tähendab seda, et see fail oli tekkinud. Ta on Changes all, vaid ta oli Unversion File all. Ta oli nagu punane. Vaata, sa pole isegi öelnud mulle, et kas jälgi või ära jälgi. Ja kui ta tahtis uut haru teha Ja haruvahetust, siis minu harus on samasugune Fail Log in view. Täpselt samas kaustas.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd temal kitil ei ole õigust nagu otsustada, vaata, Et sa tegid mingit tööd. Tegin mingisuguse faili. Sa ei ole pannud teda. Seda, et sa versioneerid. Aga kui ta läheb uude kohta, seal, On see fail juba olemas? Ta ei saa kahte faili, nagu siis hoida. Oligi nagu probleem,
Õpetaja: et, ee, ma ei saa minna uude kohta, Kuna sul on lahtised muudatused ja mina ei saa nagu kitina, nagu otsustada. Vaata, et ma võin ta prügikasti visata.
Õpetaja: Võibolla läheb sul mingi aasta töö prügikasti. Noh, kes siis? Nagu siis tuleb? Kitile tuleb kohe mingi hagi, vaata. Et Näete, kui loll tööriist,
Õpetaja: et selline mura oli õpetajaga sõitma.
Õpetaja: Neil on bussis. Jah, neil on neid muudatusi Sa saad, aga sul ei ole. Vaata seal neid. Vaata,
Õpetaja: no ma võin ära, Kui mitte te selle ka siis praegult.
Õpetaja: Kui sa tahad seda Merch. Ida, Sa saad Merch Ida peale. Fetch I. Niiöelda saad teha niimoodi, et tuled. Õpetaja veb seitsme peale ja Merchangers.
Õpetaja: Ma lihtsalt küsin, kas te saite sellega hakkama või keegi on nagu, täitsa, nagu rohkem.
Õpetaja: No See on väga tore
Õpetaja: millegi muuga.
Õpetaja: Okei, teeme, Teeme siis niimoodi. Teeme nüüd. Ma juba tunnen, et ikkagi on vaja. Vaata, et, ee,
Õpetaja: kas sul muidu juhuslikult Cloud on?
Õpetaja: Ma õppisin Cloud ei ole. Okei, siis tule lihtsalt järgi.
Õpetaja: Ma pean siis
Õpetaja: sa saad praegu Checkout I teha, Mis on see, et ta viskab prügikasti? Aga parem on alati põhimõtteliselt muudatused.
Õpetaja: Päeva lõpuks, teil peab ma natukene eraldan, siis seda, teil peab tulema niimoodi, et ee. Kui hakkate ülevalt vaatama. Teil on konteiner. On
Õpetaja: konteineris on raud. Hetkel on ainult üks roog. Kui niimoodi kinni panna on,
Õpetaja: Siis on siin kolumnid. Hetkel on ainult üks kolumn, on
Õpetaja: nii? Ja nüüd siin. Columni sees peab olema teil tegelikult kaks Aa Tv Iga niiöelda eraldatud. Ee, niiöelda input I ja seal input I all on kaks. Osa. See kastike on ise ja label on nii,
Õpetaja: Neid Peaks olema kaks tükki.
Õpetaja: Üks on ühe selle sees ja teine teine sees.
Õpetaja: Umbes niimoodi. Kui need eraldada.
Õpetaja: Ja mis me siin tahame siis teha on see, et
Õpetaja: esiteks on siis esimene Input on emaili aadress. Aga meil task is oli.
Õpetaja: Oli ta lihtsalt kasutajanimi, et me peame nüüd natukene hakkama mudima.
Õpetaja: Mitte taipeale email, vaid
Õpetaja: kui on eemal, siis ta jälgib, et on ätid ja asjad seal sees. Me ei taha Seda
Õpetaja: ei ole. See on input I Taip, mis võib siin kastikeses käia. Number tekst Password. Date, mis meil on
Õpetaja: tekst, siis me tuleme siia Taipei panema, et tekst ja juba saab ise siit valida. Tekst
Õpetaja: Id. Meil ei ole Ee, No jah, siin on see label, mis peab kattuma veits. Okei, siin natukene peab tegema selle Id. Me refaktoreerime. Mis tähendab, refaktoreerime?
Õpetaja: Muudame igal pool. Me ei saa lihtsalt Kirjutada. See pole refaktoreerimine. See on lihtsalt teksti editeerimine on ju, nii? Et me muudame, kui te vajutate siin. Peal, olete klikiga siin ja vajutate Shift F Kuus.
Õpetaja: Jätke see meelde.
Õpetaja: Shift, F, kuus.
Õpetaja: Te saaksite teha seda ka hiire ja klikkimisega. Parem klõps siin peal. Rename on Shift F, Kuus
Õpetaja: või kui minna pikalt Ja lapsel. Mitu nime? Refactor. Rename. Shift F. Kuus, üks, sama. Aga me teeme seda. See on see shortcut, Mis jääb meelde? Shift F. Kuus.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on see, et ta muudab mõlemas kohas. No see input. Kui me selle Id paneme, siis Ta Mille kohta saab olema. Username, onju?
Õpetaja: Noh, teeme siis Ee, input. User,
Õpetaja: name. Oi, user Name. Miks see näeb näiteks nii
Õpetaja: aa, igaks juhuks ja ütles, et juba. Okei, vajuta taga. Ärge vajuta veel.
Õpetaja: Ee, hästi natukene. See ikkagi pole mõeldud fronti arendamiseks.
Õpetaja: Ta võib vahel minna hulluks. Vaadake skoopi, kus Ta hakkab seda rename tegema Igal pool Project Files.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga mina siin tahan ainult selles failis toimetada. Ma tahaks Nagu talle pigem öelda. Et. Kuule,
Õpetaja: kurrend fail. Lihtsalt ma tahaks seda skoopi natuke kitsamaks tõmmata.
Õpetaja: Aa, kui me hakkame hiljem mingisuguseid muutaja nimesid asju niiöelda muutma. See vana raisk ei saa sellest Aa sellest kontekstist nii hästi aru, et ta hakkab muutma ka teistes failides,
Õpetaja: mis tegelikult ei ole seotud nagu konkreetse muutujaga, mis on nagu mingi. Ütleme, meil on File A. Me tahame seal ainult muuta. Ta muudab File base ka selle ära. Vaata, Kui on üle jaavas meil seda muretsema ei pea. Seal. Ta oskab väga hästi aru saada. Siin ta veits nagu paneb jama vahele,
Õpetaja: siis ma paneks Ee, seda skoopi veits piire, eks?
Õpetaja: Input, user. Neil ainukene. Põhjus, miks Id on üldse vajalik meil ei Ole seda, ma ütlen kohe ette. Meil ei ole seda vaja selleks, et andmed kätte saada läbi data bloki muutujate. Me hakkame suhtlema aga Siin on lihtsalt see nõue. Vaata, et label I ees peaks justkui olema. See foor. Foori foor peaks viitama. Me korra küsisime seda juba ka Cloudilt, et kas peab.
Õpetaja: Kas peab jälgima Nagu seda voes ka, et, ee, peale. No seal tõigi siis kohe välja, Vaata, et igast Vaeglugejad ja need asjad kasutavad neid, on ju? Seal on natukene. Nüüd on niimoodi, et kui siia klikkida, siis läheb see ka põlema. Tuleb Highlight Ib, et seda on kuskil veel kasutatud. Näed,
Õpetaja: kui kui klikid Selle sa lihtsalt puhtalt vaatad. Kas siin tekstis on seda veel nii Place Holder.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin. Me lihtsalt ütleme siis. Ee, see on nüüd see. Vaata, label. Põhimõtteliselt siia. Me tahame kirjutada, Kasuta ja
Õpetaja: nimi vist
Õpetaja: Kurat, ma ei ole kindel, kas on üldse vaja. Kustutaks selle ära. Minu tähendab, las ta korraks olla. Aa, ma.
Õpetaja: Ma korra ei. Jah, Nad võibolla isegi peavad kattuma, et see asi töötaks. Ee, eelkõige, et peaks tulema see labelist endast, onju Email for User. Siia, peab igal juhul tulema kasutajanimi.
Õpetaja: Minu meelest, kui ma ma panen nüüd võin viljast ka panna. Minu meelest need kaks peavad lausa nagu kattuma.
Õpetaja: Ee, muidu ei töötanud. Võibolla kohe näeme. Vaata, kasutajanimi on. Kui ma panen selle mingi vabandust, panen mingiks jamaks.
Õpetaja: Tõmbas juba kokku mul selles, et nii Panen mingi jaamaks. Kas ta siis endiselt töötab?
Õpetaja: Töötab, Siis ma vaatan Kas seda. On üldse vaja.
Õpetaja: Kui ei ole, vaja siis võtame ära. On ju? Tundub Aa, aga üks asi muutus. Vaata
Õpetaja: nüüd, ennem oli ta kogu kogunisti ees. Vaata aga nüüd, ta on koguaeg aint üleval, Näete versus kasutajana, mis siin vahe on? Üks on interaktiivne. Kui ma taastan selle,
Õpetaja: et ta on ikkagi kasutaja nimi siin,
Õpetaja: siis töötab. Ma Mäletasin õigesti. See on ikkagi vajalik
Õpetaja: Ehk siis, ee. Ja siis see label peavad kattuma.
Õpetaja: Mida kirjutab üle, kirjutab selle üle, aga peab midagi olema vä?
Õpetaja: Ei, vaata Okei, nad ei pea. Nad ei pea kattuma. Aga kui üldse pole, Vaata, siis ta enam ei tööta,
Õpetaja: see vahe on. Aga. No ma ütleks, et siis hoiame need samad. Vaata sellepärast, et. Noh, ta kandja teenendab seda Näites oli ka need samad selles mõttes nii kasutajanimi.
Õpetaja: Kas oli üldse kasutaja nimi siin? Või? Ma? Vaatan korra kasutajanimi No Midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd teeme Password iga täpi pealt samamoodi.
Õpetaja: Aa, Type Password. Siin See taip võiks jääda. Miks sest nad muidu ju näeb?
Õpetaja: Ja see ei ole praegu. See on ju ainult Lihtsalt sisse logimine. Perfect
Õpetaja: Id refaktoreerima ära, et muudab kahes kohas. Teeme siis sama või sama selle konventsiooni, Mis see oli see Shortcut
Õpetaja: Shift F. Kuus input Password.
Õpetaja: Ainult label. I jaoks on see vajalik. Jällegi, Projekt Files on siin. Ma tuleks paneks. Ma lihtsalt nagu soovitan olla Refaktureerimisel Frontis. Väga ettevaatlik.
Õpetaja: Jaavas. Me ei pea üldse muretsema. Ülihästi töötab
Õpetaja: see. See, sa mõtled, see. Ja see. Need peab kattuma,
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et Siis kui. Ee. See on nüüd see hea tava haataja meil tegelikult seda nõuab. Kui on nüüd mingisugune. Siin oli ka väiksed asjad. Vaata, Et Mäletate, kui meil oli näiteks checkbox?
Õpetaja: Kui nad on omavahel Connected label ja checkbox, siis sa said ka selle sõna peal label klikkida Ja see tikkis sisse välja Checkbox. Ja mäletate, Tingimused
Õpetaja: tuleb meelde. Ei, mees, naine,
Õpetaja: midagi taolist, Aga see on ka selle, jaoks et kui Vaeglugeja kasutab oma mingit aparatuuri
Õpetaja: ja ta läheb selle välja peale Ta paneb. Ta paneb, et läheb kassi sisse, läheb vilkuma,
Õpetaja: siis see label on seotud selle kastiga. Ja tema kõnesüntesaator saab öelda Kasutaja nimi.
Õpetaja: Saate aru.
Õpetaja: Näiteks praegu Ärme rohkem juurdle. Hea küsimus, Cloudile, onju? Kui Ee, tekitab segadust. Miks see peab nii olema?
Õpetaja: Kirjuta, et miks peab. Miks peab. Label fooria input olema? Omavahel seotud, Näiteks,
Õpetaja: aga lähme edasi. Aa, Me peame liikuma ka. Aa, saate küsida neid küsimusi. Kõike siin on ja tahaks hoopis muuta Eesti keeles.
Õpetaja: Parool ja Copy baseb siis selle siia lihtsalt parool.
Õpetaja: Nüüd kui nad. Miks ta nüüd praegu tõstis? Teksti siia vaata, näete seda joont Siin
Õpetaja: ta praegult nagu loeb. Et see Joon Vanasti oli kuskil umbes siin.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, miks sa joon on nihkunud.
Õpetaja: Vanasti See joon oli märksa kitsam.
Õpetaja: See On intelligisest endast tulevad seaded, Mis on Ära paika. Mitu tähemärki see joon? Umbes on Nagu mingi laius.
Õpetaja: Pakkuge, mis see joon on? Ajas läinud paremale poole
Õpetaja: ekraanid lähevad laiemaks. Vanasti olid ruudu kujulased
Õpetaja: valdavalt Mäletate Crt? Monitorid võtsid lauast ära. Mingi pool pool lauast võtsid ära. Mida suurem monitor oli, seda suuremaid Lauda oli vaja. No täna nagu pane seinale. Ja nagu pidiraam,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, see on niuke Soovituslik joon. Ma olen sellest rääkinud. Ka kood võib siit üle. Tegelikult, ee, et tarkvaraarenduses keegi s seda tagasi ei põrgata. Aga, noh, mitte niimoodi, nagu loomulikult. Nagu, kui see,
Õpetaja: kui see Kood oleks nagu mingi. No siis ongi, niimoodi, et ma vaatan siin koodi. Oot, oot, oot, mis siin nüüd toimub? Nagu, Vaata ja no Kui ma pean niimoodi koodi lugema, siis ma ei suuda seda enam tegelikult lugeda.
Õpetaja: Ee, Niukene. Noh, ütleme suht liberaalselt, võib üle minna mitte, nagu, et Oi. Üks, kaks, tähte läheb märki üle. See on Fine, vaata vaid. Noh, kui sa leiad, et see parem on hoida ühel Real Koodireal loetavuse huvides. Sa võid lasta sealt veidi üle. Küll mul küll keegi kunagi midagi ei öelnud.
Õpetaja: Mm aga
Õpetaja: need samad tööriistad See võib ise sinu eest lõpuks kuskile suruda. Ta ka alla, Kui ta muidugi on üks koodirida. Ta ei pruugi seda jaavast näiteks teha, vaata. Et sa saad ka sundida, et ta enamvähem jääks sinna. Nii, How, ütle see login. Vaata, näete nende kaste vahel on ilusti vahe sees,
Õpetaja: Siis miks on niimoodi? Vaata, et. Et, ee, see kast
Õpetaja: ja see kast hoiavad omavahel mõnusalt Niiöelda Vahet, Aga miks sa nuppi ei hoia. Vahet Jah, ülemisel kastil. Ütleb, et hoia minust alumine asi Ee, kolme võrra Nagu edasi.
Õpetaja: Aga siin ei ole Aga Järgmisena. Tulebki See napp Nupp on ju? Sest mina lepin kohe kokku. Vaata, teeme niimoodi, et. Noh, ma saaks nüüd tulla. Siia näiteks. Vaata Buttonist sai öelda Mt Margin top kolm näiteks. Hoia minust üleval. Aga me teeme niukse süsteemi kogu aeg. Me vaikime siia kogu aeg. Ütleme
Õpetaja: et meil ei tekiks, Nagu vaata kuskil. Ütleme, et hoia mind ülemist eemal ja nii edasi on, ju et oleks, Muidu ma tulen. Panen näiteks siit, kui ma Selle süsteemi järgi tahaks panna Siia Sa nüüd tahate kirjutada? Mb kolm, onju?
Õpetaja: No aga kui nad nüüd omavahel ütlevad veel vahet, siis on ju topeltvahe Saate aru, et teeme niukse lihtsa süsteemi, et me kogu aeg manakeerime seda vertikaal Space niimoodi, et me ütleme lihtsalt, et hoia minust alumise eemal.
Õpetaja: Siis on niuke ühtne lähenemine. Meil on lihtne kontrollida vähem mingisuguseid pugiseid ja imelike Aa imelikke vahesid.
Õpetaja: No nüüd võiks mõelda Et visuaalselt on nagu. Et. Oi, väga tore. Aga ta võiks olla siin keskel ju. Miks ta niimoodi on? Kuskil kaugustes Vaatan, kas siin Oli ka midagi. Mingit, ee, headerit ei olnud. Nüüd tuleb mängu see,
Õpetaja: et me peame mõtlema. Vaata, et, ee, mille sees on, ee, need elemendid,
Õpetaja: et mis on nagu pärand. Kui me vaatame praegu, et räägime nendest siin, nendest elementidest, mille sees nad on,
Õpetaja: No ta on, ee, Ta on selles
Õpetaja: ridade mõttes. Ee, see niiöelda Element Neli. On ju see
Õpetaja: koll sees? Nii. Aga mul võib neid kolle olla. Mitmeid on Nii
Õpetaja: Mul võib siin mitu kolli olla. Aga kuidas ma saan? Öelda Vaata, et ma võin Ju ma korra dublitseerin. Seda, Vaata, et ärge Tee seda kohta kaasa. Tehke, mul võib ju nii ka olla, onju? Saate mõttest aru,
Õpetaja: et kui mina tahaksin, et nad oleks keskel, siis Me peame mõtlema, et. Oota. Aga mille sees nemad üldse on? Ma tahaks, et kogu paigutus oleks keskel,
Õpetaja: mille sees nemad on,
Õpetaja: Rose ees, Onju? Vaata Rose ees siis, kui ma tahan nüüd mudida. Vaata, et ei. Minu sees on siin mingisugune Aa vaja hoida, nagu seda, et Asjad hoiaksid kas kuskile keskele või äärde. Vaata siis ma pean aru saama, et kus ma saan seda nagu panna
Õpetaja: ja seda saab Row sisse panna. Sest nad on ju Row sees nagu pärast, kavatsen selle alumise ära kustutada. Aga kui ma panen praegu nüüd siia, tulen ja Paned justified
Õpetaja: Justifine Content Center. Mis tähendab, mida tähendab Josify Content Center joonda?
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd nad on kahekesi keskel. No ma loomulikult kavatsen selle ära kustutada alumise. See on meie eesmärk.
Õpetaja: No see on. Võibolla mul Praegu tundub, et ma paneks tegelikult siia ühe siia ühe heederi ka juurde taskis. Seda polegi enda. Oleks kuidagi parem jälgida. Vaata, et teha H Üks
Õpetaja: ja sisseloogimine Midagi taolist natukene kuidagi muutuks
Õpetaja: nagu paremaks ja Paneks ka sellele siia klassi külge. Ee, Glass.
Õpetaja: Ja ütleks, ee, Mis see Mb? Kolm onju?
Õpetaja: Mingi Hoia mingit vahet.
Õpetaja: Margin Button kolm, Noh, Vaeval näeb, käib kah
Õpetaja: kogu aeg vaikselt. See Aqua siin vahepeal vilgub
Õpetaja: seda. Ee, mul on see Brauseri Cash is on veel See Brauser veel mäletab, et kunagi siin indeks oli hoopis teistsugune. Ma ei taha seda kustutada ära. Sellepärast ma ei viitsi nagu kõike. Ära kuidas
Õpetaja: koodi Kõik, mis ma tegin juurde, oli lihtsalt selle koolile. Panin ühe H. Ühe,
Õpetaja: et see on sisse logimine. Panin selle, et hoia nagu seda alumist kasti kolme võrra eemal. Rohkem mitte midagi.
Õpetaja: Nii on enamvähem mingi niuke tulemus Okei.
Õpetaja: Nüüd siis hakkame rääkima nüüd sellest, et kuidas me Saame sellest kastist sisu kätte. Hetkel on meil. Tere, maailm. Teeme jälle nagu tere ja ütleb kasutajanimi parool midagi taolist. Vaata
Õpetaja: nüüd siia, tuleb Siis mängu.
Õpetaja: See asi, millest ma siin olen, Ennem jahu. Siin
Õpetaja: see
Õpetaja: nüüd. Kui me vaatame Süntaxit, ma. Kui mul kuskil see alles oleks, Ma tahaks seda tegelikult korda teha. Siin peaksid olema nurgalised täägid
Õpetaja: Template. On vaata. Htm element meetod. On aga, vaadake korra lihtsalt. Kuidas, Data on defineeritud data. Ee, sulud. Ja siis tuleb loogiliselt sulud. Scoop, mida see meenutab? Mis asi see on, Sisuliselt
Õpetaja: süntaksi mõttes, mida see meenutab Noh, ta isegi on lausa süntakse mõttes, mitte ei meenuta
Õpetaja: Ta on meetod. On nimi on parameetrid. Tehakse justkui need sulud ja on skoop Datablokk on oma olemiselt meetod
Õpetaja: kirjaviisis. Ta tegelikult on meetod ja seda võib kujutada natukene ette. Vaata, et et see nupp ja siis saaks omavahel nagu ee. Üksteisele ligi, siis on nagu mingi meetod, mida niiöelda see sisemine sisemine niiöelda voe suudab kasutada, et hei. Kutsu välja data Blokk, mis tagastab
Õpetaja: andmudeli objekti. Vaata, kus sees ongi. Need muutujad, et seda seda võibki mõelda. Nagu mingi asi, mida mida mõlemad pooled saavad kuidagi välja kutsuda.
Õpetaja: Mida sa saad välja kutsuda? Meetodeid, et see. See süntaks, Mis me nüüd kohe kirjutame, Tahaks seda käsitsi ka natukene kirjutada. See tundub alguses väga nagu.
Õpetaja: Aga see ei ole Sigrimigri. Kui hakkate mõtlema nii nagu mina, seda räägin, et kuidagi nagu endale, teha see loogiliseks, et alati saab kirjutada. Näete, meetoditel on oma blokk. On
Õpetaja: On oma blokk. Vaata, metsad.
Õpetaja: Temal on ka Niukene. Noh, tal on nagu eriline süntaks, Aga meetodil on oma blokk see alla. Me tahame nüüd teha seda keskmist blokki, meetodite ja templeid vahele. Ma tõmban korra need kokku. On Meil Templeid on meil. Ma nüüd tahan teha nende kahe vahele. Kas saate aru sellest mõttest, onju? Kahevahelised suhtluskanalid.
Õpetaja: See ongi see Kõik see, mis me siia sisse praegu kirjutame. Kas blokid ja asjad teeme Ja need on valikud.
Õpetaja: Me ütleme, et me tahame niukest valikut, Tulge siia peale, neimi. Kirjutage data
Õpetaja: nüüd. Data on oma olemuselt meetod. See data on nimi. Nimi on olemas, mis tuleb peale meetodil peale nime
Õpetaja: sulud.
Õpetaja: Kui siis saab parameetreid panna. Siin pole vaja Nüüd meetodil on keha
Õpetaja: siis, et see, keha See tähendab seda, et tal on Body. Tal on Skoop.
Õpetaja: Coopi saab teha ainult loogiliste sulgudega
Õpetaja: mentorit, et meil on vaja natuke. Rohkem teksti. Miks siin see punane on? Mingi Punane väike jooneke
Õpetaja: koma. Vaatad need plokid tuleb komadega järele, vä?
Õpetaja: Nüüd me hakkame niukest lauset, et Data on oma olemuselt meetod, mis tagastab Andme objekti
Õpetaja: tagastab. Tagastab, Mis ma võiks siia kirjutada. Return tagastab. Andme objekti. Objekt ringu peale.
Õpetaja: Kas integral või String ei ole objekt, Nad on tegelikult selles mõttes nagu primitiivid, mis? Kuidas on objekt kõige otsemas kirja kirjaviisis literal? Kui ta saab objekti tekitada hästi lühikeselt, õppisime just Seda ka.
Õpetaja: Jah, Loogilised sulud. Nii kui me nüüd vaatame seda uuesti ära.
Õpetaja: Data on olemuselt meetod mis? Tagastab. Ja nüüd vaadake andmemudeli objekti andmeobjekti. Lihtsalt ärge seda mudelit mõelge. Mulle meeldib seda sõna mudeli kasutada, sest et see, on kohe siin, süntaksis varsti sees
Õpetaja: nüüd see koht on, Siis kus me saame välja mõelda sildikesi, sildikesi ehk.
Õpetaja: Mida muutujaid mõtleme niimoodi? Aga nüüd need on väga erilised muutujad.
Õpetaja: Need on nagu Väga erilised muutujad. Need ongi siis sihukesed muutujad, mida me saame seal üleval Templitis
Õpetaja: saame kasutada. Saame viidata ja saame all Javascriptis viidata. Me Jagame neid. Need On väga erilised muutujad.
Õpetaja: Need on. See ongi. See ongi see moodus. Kuidas me hakkame omavahel? Nüüd siin suhtleme ja nagu Paneme nagu paika. Vaata, et, ee, mis seal saab näha? Ja mis andmeid me sealt kätte soovime saada.
Õpetaja: Nii me kavatseme siia. Ee, sidu Siia soovime muuta, et. Ja kui ma tulen praegu korra templitesse, ärge te hoidke te nagu puhtalt veel seda asja korraks, onju? Nüüd ma Küsin teilt. Vaata, onju, et
Õpetaja: kui mina sooviksin ühte muutujat, mis oleks seotud selle kasutaja nime kassliga,
Õpetaja: siis mis võiks olla selle muutuja nimi?
Õpetaja: Ma soovin mõelda siia ühte muutujat ühte sildikest, kus sees hakkab olema selle kasti sisu, mis võiks olla selle sildikese nimi,
Õpetaja: aga, no kasutajanimi Küll aga muuta. Ja mis keeles võiks olla eks?
Õpetaja: Inglise keeles ühes keeles. String tekst
Õpetaja: inglise keel, et me ei taha panna sinna selle Sildikese nimeks Kasutajanimi. Sest et. Hea küll, see keelsus. Ma Meil on Hiina arendaja.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate, Hiina arendaja, kes ta hakkab kunagi Eesti keelt oskama. Kindlasti mitte. No tegelikult. Näiteid on küll saadetes nagu need ongi, mingid pool aastat eestis olnud. Juba räägivad. Mina ei tea, kuidas nad seda teevad. Aga vaata, arendajad. Selles mõttes tahaks ikka programmeerida inglise keeles. Programmeerimis Keel on inglise keel.
Õpetaja: See, et meil on siin Content On Eesti keel on Fine, Sest et. Noh, me tahame, et Eesti keelne sõit, mida iganes, onju? Aga see programmeerimis keel, see osa on alati inglise keel. Ee, niiöelda alati,
Õpetaja: kui te kuskile teete proovitööd ja teete mingi eestikeelsete muutuvate asjadega.
Õpetaja: Ohohoo, no kood võib olla väga hea, Siis võibolla keegi annab andeks. Aga nagu, kindlasti, nagu see on. Ei nagu kindel, ei.
Õpetaja: No siis mõtlemegi. Ja see nüüd on siin Java Scripti objekt
Õpetaja: Mäletad, Kui me tegime selle customer
Õpetaja: ja siis panime mingi First name ja last name või midagi taolist, on ju? Nüüd siin on täpselt samamoodi vaata, et me kirjutame.
Õpetaja: Nii siin ei tule võrdusmärki.
Õpetaja: Mis siin võrdusmärgi asemel on? Ei ole punkt. Kool on
Õpetaja: koolon, on, Mis annab selle väärtuse Nii, ee, nüüd mina tahan siia panna. Mul on võimalus panna ka väike väärtus,
Õpetaja: mis võiks olla väike väärtus first Name Il, see hakkab. Me hakkame kahepidiselt siduma. Seda automaatselt Hakkame siduma seda muutujat selle kastiga. Mida iganes me anname sinna väärtuseks, on kohe alguse sees. Kas me soovime, et meil siin alguses? Ee, oleks midagi ees Selles kastis
Õpetaja: nagu ei soovi. Vist on ju mis? Me soovime oma väike väärtuseks. Siis panna
Õpetaja: Tühjuseks ei saa niimoodi tühjuseks seda jätta.
Õpetaja: Kolmkümmend viis tema No vot sa oled juba õige õigel Seeing,
Õpetaja: ühekordsed jutumärgid. Vaata, et selles mõttes midagi. Peame siia panema. See tüüp siin on nõutud. See tegelikult nüüd annab aimu meil tüübist ka, mis see, Mis see justkui ideeliselt võiks? Käia? Ärge unustage ära. Vaata, me tüüpe pole. Ainult kaks. Varianti. Defineerida on lett ja konst, on ju, aga need Ei, ei defineeri tüüpi,
Õpetaja: vaid seda, et kas saab sinna objekt saab taustal muutuda või mitte, on ju Aga meie iseendale märku. Vaata praegu, et. Hei, No me ei taha siia sisse panna, Rain.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et pärast muidu seda hakkaks seal kuvama, onju? Me tahame, et ta oleks tühistriing, aga ta annab meile ka märku. Tegelikult, see datablokis on tegelikult siin. Vähe sellest, et on päriselt objekt, kus sees saavad olla Andmed, mida me jagame. Vaata, niiöelda selle ja vahel on ju ühtlasi. See on ka meie mudel.
Õpetaja: Ta räägib meile. Vaata, et me kasutame siin sellist muutujat First name. Ja tema tüüp on tegelikult vaikimisi. Me loeme seda, kui
Õpetaja: string, sest et tema väike väärtus on tühist ring, Kui see oleks mingi, number,
Õpetaja: siis ta võiks olla näiteks parem null. Näiteks,
Õpetaja: et seal on mingi väärtus Niikuinii See saab sisu kuskilt mujalt Vahet pole, vaata aga see annab meile märku. Vaata, et tegemist on numbriga. No ja kui on mingi puulöön, siis seal, on mingi False Ja need ongi nendes väike väärtused, et First Name on paigas.
Õpetaja: Aga proovime nüüd seda siis Nüüd see siin on andmemudeli objekt, see on mudel.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Kui meie tahame siduda seda selle kastiga, paneme kõik muud asjad kinni. Jätame lihtsalt selle kasutaja nimi siin niimoodi ette.
Õpetaja: See on Meie kast olete nõus?
Õpetaja: See on see päriselt See kast. Pikk klõps, Klõps. Klõps Klõps on ju? On nii
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui meie tahame siduda seda muutujat selle kastiga kahepiiliselt kahes suunas. Ehk siis, mis iganes on siin. Väärtus tuleb siia kasti Ja Kui mina kirjutan mingit teksti, ümber, Siis see elab siin muutujas, saate aru?
Õpetaja: Siis meie tuleme siia sisse, Lepime kokku, et niuksed voeasjad jätame me ettepoole.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see ongi siis See äge asi. See raamistik on nagu mõelnud välja omad, sõnad ja asjad, mis tema jaoks midagi tähendab Ja mida tema siis taustal pärast ise toimetab ja paneb selle lõpp koodi kokku. Nagu Vaata, mida me kunagi isegi ei näe. On ju siis valdavalt hakkavad. Arvake ära, mis Tähega.
Õpetaja: Ei, mis tähega me ei saa,
Õpetaja: ma küsin. Alfabetis on A Zini. Mis tähega? Pakute, Et voeasjad hakkavad veega nagu voe
Õpetaja: nüüd mis Mind võiks siin. Huvitada Nendest valikutest
Õpetaja: Juba paindimine on ühe ühe tänavaga, mis siin võiks silma jääda, Sest ma rõhutasin ühte sõna kogu aeg Siin
Õpetaja: mudel, veebodel. Põmm.
Õpetaja: Kui panete, vali, Lähed sinna. Pange tähele. Siin on kaks varianti. Üks on, ee. Veemodel on kooloniga, teine mitte. Me Tahame siin seda, Mitte kooloniga. Vee model,
Õpetaja: mis ta juba pakub. Vaata siia sulgudesse, et millega sa tahad ee niiöelda ühendada ja isegi ta näitab, et tegemist on string. Kus ta seda teab? Ta lihtsalt vaatab, mis on väike väärtus tühistring.
Õpetaja: Me Ei, me ei, kirjuta, me ei ole. Tegelikult poes saab teha niimoodi ka et tüübid on ära defineeritud. Kompilaator? Noh, kompilaatori laadne toode ütleb meile nagu vaata et kui kuskil on kuidagi valesti asjad seotud. Ütleme stringi. Üritame mingeid numbrid suruda ja vastupidi. Vaata, onju,
Õpetaja: et ta ei ole nagu tüübikindel, aga aga vähemalt nagu mõistab seda, kuidas see asi peaks praegu tehniliselt olema?
Õpetaja: Vajut The First Name. Mis värvi see on?
Õpetaja: Mis Värvi see on?
Õpetaja: Nüüd pange tähele. Edaspidi kogu aeg. See Staff on siin lilla
Õpetaja: ja meil on nii hea aru saada, et millal me räägime selle databloki muutujatest,
Õpetaja: kui See Teil koodis ei ole lillaga. Te sooviksite, et ta oleks lilla? Siis midagi? On valesti.
Õpetaja: Jõuame selleni ka. No Teeme proovi korra Ma Teeme esialgu ühtepidi proove, et siin on mingi sisu.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma nüüd tulen lehele, siis kas mul on siin kasutajanimi?
Õpetaja: Ma teen Refresh, Näe, Tulen täiesti lehele. On siin. Aa, on
Õpetaja: Kas ta. Just tõestasime endale proof of kontsertina ära, et mida iganes me sinna kirjutame, see jookseb siia kasti,
Õpetaja: sest et tema, on spetsiaalses blokis. See muutuja täpselt siukse süntaksiga Voe saab sellele meetodile ligi, tema saab mis tahel hetkel ise käivitada seda, et anna mulle data ja see tagastab kogu objekti. Tema näeb, et siin on First name objekt välja kasutatud. Ta saab selle sisu kätte ja ta topib ise meie ees Selle sinna input I,
Õpetaja: kui lihtne see nüüd oli.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd siis vaatame teistpidi, Mina Kirjutan selle ära, onju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kuidas ma saan juba praegu vaadata, et see asi töötab, on see, et ma teen inspekt.
Õpetaja: Noh, see on See asi, mis ühel grupil tuli. Oi aa, ma läksin vaale nupule pihta. Aa, inspekt. Ma läksin kohe
Õpetaja: Kui ma. Nüüd teen selle voetöriista lahti. Mis? Minul on? Siia vasakule, et räägitud kenasti
Õpetaja: tulen. Ee, et olen komponent seal. Kas teil on see must või valge
Õpetaja: must? Väga Hea Valge, aga lihtsalt on tüütu. Nii on hästi hea vaadata, onju? Meil leht on valge. Kui ma nüüd tulen, klikin selle komponentidest, Vaadake, Kui ma siin niimoodi liigun, siis ta näitab ka, Vaata, et näed. View on kogu see roheline osa meil, veel et see tuleb sellest Failist. Kui ma nüüd klikin selle, peale,
Õpetaja: siis vaadake, et data on eraldi välja toodud, on siin First name ja hetkel on väärtus Pbb, See tähendab seda, et kui mina siin praegult kirjutan, näiteks. Noh, panen siin Ccc,
Õpetaja: siis tegelikult seal muutujas see sisu. Automaatselt ise uueneb Palju me siin. Koodi kirjutasime, et niukest funktsionaalsust ise ehitada. Väga vähe.
Õpetaja: See ongi raamistiku võlu Mõnus Lõpuks Fronton on ka mõnus, kui me tegime Siin valid teed? Ee,
Õpetaja: seitse aastat tagasi, Mis iganes. No siis, see oli ikka väga rõve, mis me tegime. Ja see on ikka väga Mõnus, kui ma vaatasin ka, mis asja niimoodi nii mõnus Tegelikult on päris mõnus toimetada, nagu et sa tegelikult tead, et taustal toimub tegelikult Ikka väga, väga palju Action Id, mida me ei pea kirjutama.
Õpetaja: Vee model põmm muuta Tatablokis See muuta ei ole olemas kõik
Õpetaja: kõik rohkem, Mitte midagi, nagu lihtsalt töötab. Ja siin sellest tööriistast saab ka tegelikult proovida. Näiteks kui on mingi objekt Näiteks. Näete, kui ma panin üks Asi ka mida Pange tähele. Mis värvi see on?
Õpetaja: Oranz oranž tähistab siin stringi.
Õpetaja: Kui teinekord on mingisugune. Näiteks mingi Customer Id üks ja Sa näed, et see on punane.
Õpetaja: Siis on natukene valesti, Sellepärast, et kui panna Editit, siis te näete neid jutumärke. Ka, et on hoopis tege. Noh, kui te näete, nagu teie soov on mingi Id.
Õpetaja: Üks on ju? Noh, et see oleks nagu mingi customer Id Üks Oot Oot, oot värv on vale. Siis võibolla potentsiaalselt vaja tekkida probleeme Sellepärast, et isegi kui see tüüp,
Õpetaja: isegi kui see tüüp oleks siin taustal, Number Vahet pole, kõik kastid tegelikult sisuliselt annavad teksti. Kui sul on seal mingi Date selector, siis seal on tegelikult lihtsalt kuupäevas ringi kujul,
Õpetaja: Kui sul on siin mingisugune input Aa ja on number. Ja sul on mingi number üks ja mis iganes, siis tegelikult nendest kastides, ta Võtab ikkagi teksti
Õpetaja: et seda, peab meeles hoidma All In good time. Kui on ee selle jaoks spetsia tähelepanu vaja nii
Õpetaja: meil, mis me teeme, on see, et me selle databloki loomulikult teeme tühjaks.
Õpetaja: Mitte datoblokki, vaid selle first name I. Me ei soovi vaikeväärtust
Õpetaja: ja nüüd me Lisame juurde siia. Veel midagi, mis me lisame siia juurde. See on meil ära vaadatud.
Õpetaja: Pole vaja mingeid meetodeid. Me kõigepealt teeme ära, selle, et me hetkel ei saa seda sisu kuidagi ju kätte, on nii
Õpetaja: Noh, vara veel midagi teha sellepärast, et kui sa teed veemodel ja Nüüd hakkad siit Selectima. Siis ta pakub hetkel.
Õpetaja: Meil ei ole midagi siduda. Meil ei ole veel seda Muutujat on ju See tähendab seda, et me tuleme siia datablokki
Õpetaja: Siin, kus meil on First name. Mis ma siia kirjutan,
Õpetaja: enne kui ma üldse midagi teen Koma, mis ma Nüüd teen Controll D.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Control, kaks siis V ja siia kirjutab.
Õpetaja: Jah, kõik
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd. Kes juba oskab, läheb proovib. Input. Ist Paneb ühe tühiku sinna juurde ta oleks ruumi sinna atribuuti kirjutada
Õpetaja: ja kirjutab veemodel ja valib Password.
Õpetaja: No ma tulen. Ka Ärge nüüd Label Isse Pange, onju.
Õpetaja: Label ei ole interaktiivne või mudel pääseväärt kõik olemas.
Õpetaja: Nüüd See patt on Ee, mis praegult klikkides lihtsalt käivitab meetodit, mis on siin all. Hello World.
Õpetaja: Ee, Mina tahaks selle ära muuta. Nüüd, et, ee, kuidas ma seda muudan ära, kui ma siin peal olen,
Õpetaja: kontrollida
Õpetaja: ei Ei taha nii taha. Miks sellepärast, kui ma selle kirjutan üle. Mul on siin all meetod. Hello World läks halliks. Mis temaga nüüd siis on ei ole kasutuses. Tahaks muuta. Ära nagu seda nime siis teeb. Kuus ja siin ei ole vahet. Kas sa teed seda siin,
Õpetaja: Või sa teed seda siin siin all. Vaata, vahet pole, kummas sa teed? Ta muudab selle ära. Mõlemas See on refaktureerimine. Rename konkreetsemalt muudaks selle ka ära rename. Selle
Õpetaja: ma panen. Muidu võiks login ka panna. Vaata aga, see login on niimoodi, et kas te võtate seda tegusõna või See on nagu et see on nagu nimisõna. Nagu tegevus. Vaata, on ju? Ma panen korra
Õpetaja: Exaccute login Teame Niimoodi ma juba ettenägelikult Näen, et, ee. Noh, siin võib olla ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, Okei, hea küll, Paneme lihtsalt logi hetkel, praegu et teeme login.
Õpetaja: Me saame seda refaktureerida hiljem. Ka kui tahame login.
Õpetaja: No see muutis nüüd ainult aa meetodi nime ära.
Õpetaja: Aga tegevus on ikka see, et ta praegu lihtsalt ütleb Tere, maailm, onju? Seda sisu ta veel ei kasuta
Õpetaja: Aa, Jumal temaga.
Õpetaja: Nii, ma arvan, et ee. Siinkohal teeme hästi väikse pausi
Õpetaja: ja ja Ma teen, ma teen ära siis kõik, kes tahavad, tulevad ee järgi. Mis asi?
Õpetaja: Aa, okei. Ma ei jõudnudki seda. Selle Muudame ära. Username,
Õpetaja: See oleks varsti välja tulnud kui ma. Refaktureerin siin. Vaata, see ongi hästi tähtis. Ma parem tulen, võtan refaktor.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: oota korra. Kas nüüd Jäid ka mingisugused Ee, input Username. See klapib. Vaata, onju see näide? Lihtsalt oli mul mingi lamp.
Õpetaja: Nii, ma teen nüüd Comiti ära, ja Siis buss, buss, puss, buss.
Õpetaja: Kes tahab, saab enda roll Back Id juba ära teha
Õpetaja: ja teha. Siis teeme siis pausi.
Õpetaja: Ma korra siis Vaikselt. Nüüd keskendun natukene ja ma vaatan korra nüüd, mida ma järgmisena materjalidest tahan teile näidata
Õpetaja: Ee, panen Ee, screen record I ka pausi peale. Nii et palun aida. Recording
Õpetaja: Vist sai niikuinii peale. On ju?
Õpetaja: On või? Ei, ole. Näete nii, Ee, Järgmine asi, millest ma tahan rääkida,
Õpetaja: eks? Ma leidsin ma juba eel eile. Tegelikult tahtsin Ee, neid samu pilte leida, aga mul Lihtsalt too hetk. Ma vaatan, kas ta Lubab või ei luba ka Mul on praegu Edit režiim. Siis lähme korra. Bye, bye, ee. Ma panen kohe teile siia, et palun vaadake Ära
Õpetaja: Introduction to Rest Waple Services. Client Front and Server Back and server database silmad alla Kui olete ära vaadanud. Ee, ühesõnaga materjalid, mida võiks Siis esimesel võimalusel kodus Ee, ära vaadata.
Õpetaja: Kohe. Ei pea. Kohe. Ei, pea samal ajal. Jah, multidasking naisterahvad võivad mehed nagu väidetavalt ei oska seda kunsti.
Õpetaja: No mina ei oska kusjuures tõesti. Kui mul naine tuleb midagi rääkima ja ma sama. Noh, tegelikult ta võiks olla juba õpik, kui ma nagu vähegi progemisega midagi seotud. Isegi mitte tingimata. Kui ma olen nagu arvutisse naerutatud, et et kui sa pöördud minu poole, Vaata, et siis kõigepealt öelda
Õpetaja: Saame kokku kümne minuti pärast ma. Ei tea ennast tule. Välja vaata. Et, ma sa. Võid rääkida mulle midagi ennast. Ma ei kuule, ma lihtsalt olen Endiselt veel mõttes. Vaata, ja mida järsamalt sisse sõidetakse, seda rohkem ma nagu ei suuda jälgida,
Õpetaja: et Ma lihtsalt ei suuda. Ee teemad. Mida siis võiks vaadata? Ma topin võibolla siia mingisuguseid asju veel päeva jooksul juurde kui tekib vajadust Ee, Panin ka selle silmad alla, kui olete ära vaadanud. Noh, teeme niimoodi. Ausalt vaata. Pange sinna alla, et ega ma kontrollima ei tule ka, midagi. Aga kui paljud on midagi ära vaadanud? Veebiteenused,
Õpetaja: teenused on tegelikult siis. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee Suures, pildis ta tegelikult on nagu arhitektuur, Ee, ta ei olegi otseselt nagu mingi, noh, eraldi tehnoloogia, vaid ta on lihtsalt Hdp Niiöelda suhtlusviis. Kuidas on võimalik saada süsteemide vahel sõnumeid Ee, niimoodi. Et nad üksteisest saavad aru, et mis nagu peab toimuma hakkama.
Õpetaja: Kõige esimene asi, mis? Ma tahan, ee, rääkida seda, et need sõnumid
Õpetaja: selle Kursuse jooksul. Sõnumid, mis meil hakkavad minema meie enda Back and serverile. Meil ei ole hetkel veel back and server It. Astetajale ei ole Aga Ideeliselt nad lõpuks hakkavad minema. Meie sinna Nagu selles restoranis. See tagaruum on ju?
Õpetaja: Anna mulle midagi, Too toitu Ee, Meil sama ongi, et ma soovin midagi. Aa, me Veel seda ei puuduta, Aga siis siin hakkab mingi action pihta, kus erinevad kihid. Niiöelda tulevad toovad andmebaasist andmed ja saavad neid kätte, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja meil praegu siis hakkabki olema, niimoodi et meid meile meie brauser saadab frontendile sõnumi, et näita mulle mingit vaadet.
Õpetaja: Tema paneb selle kõik kokku Tegelikult ta annab ka kupatuse ka selle niiöelda arvutisse tagasi ja siis sealt hakkavad minema sõnumid Tegelikult Backendi, et see joonis on hästi. Natuke niimoodi. Selles mõttes eksitav, et see suhtlus käib tegelikult läbi Fronted serveri,
Õpetaja: et andmed, mis on vaja ära tuua, Aga siin joonisel. Siis me näitame, et põhimõtteliselt meie front sisuliselt vajab
Õpetaja: selle Html I kokkupanemise jaoks. Aa andmeid on see Arusaadav, siin on joonis ka. Too mulle mingi Htm Locations andmed. Too need pangaautomaatide asukohad. Ee, andmed tulevad sisse.
Õpetaja: Andmebaasis saadakse need kätte pannakse Jason kokku ja tagastatakse. Me oleme korra seda juba nagu arutanud, onju? Nüüd, Kas saadab Frontend Meie enda server saadab sõnumi Back end ile, Küsib andmeid nii
Õpetaja: või brauserist Otse Kõik päringud saab panna. Näiteks saadab sõnumi back and serverile ja me saame andmed või on sisse ehitatud, võimalus, et sa saad käivitada veebiteenuseid. Sõnum läheb
Õpetaja: Back and serverisse. Kas me kasutame niukest tarkvararengu? Postman? On keegi kunagi kuulnud?
Õpetaja: See on siis Selline tarkvara, millega on väga mõnus nagu saatega sõnumeid Ee, süsteemidele. Jätta oma mingid siia alla ja nii edasi. Edasi. Edasi. Hästi, nagu võimekas Programm,
Õpetaja: kes saadab selle sõnumi Me vaatame Sväger Svägerini jõuame ka. See On nagu võlts veebileht, mis tegelikult Aa meie süsteemi pealt niiöelda, pannakse linnulujooksult kokku meie eest. Automaat tekitatakse. Niukene keskkond, kus on mõnus nagu näha, mida? Mis Veebiteenused süsteemis. Meil on Olemas seal Backendis ja siis neid kohe proovida.
Õpetaja: Lõppkokkuvõttes on vahet. Pole, kes tegelikult saadab sõnumi meil sellele. Back and serverile. Peamine point on see, et meil on niuke Elukas nagu Back and server,
Õpetaja: Kellele lähevad sõnumid Kas see tuleb meie brauserist?
Õpetaja: Kas see tuleb läbi meie Front and serveri? Kas see tuleb Otse Browserist. Kas sa tuled? Kas sul. Tuleb? Need on sõnumid,
Õpetaja: mis tegelikult lähevad Back and serverile. Probleem.
Õpetaja: Meil ei ole veel back and Server It.
Õpetaja: Ja ma tegelikult saaksin isegi selle teha. Võtan eelmise kursuse Back and serveri panen püsti ja taustal muudkui vastab neile. Vaata, onju Väga tore,
Õpetaja: Ee, aga
Õpetaja: alguses ma seda polnud. Noh, ma saaksin seda teha, aga mina siis, nagu leidsin nagu lihtsama lahenduse, et ma kogu aeg. Olin selle asja juures. Ma õppisin seda Backendi. Ja Räägin. Mingid veebiteenused ja mingid sõnumid ja asjad ja see pilt, nii, nagu minu Enda valid ees oli põhimõtteliselt alles siis, kui jõuad. Lõpuks jookseb kokku. Vaata, oot, oot, oot. Siin omavahel suhtlevad. Ja mille jaoks
Õpetaja: Kogu aeg. Oli see probleem? Tegelikult keegi ei saanud ööd ega mütsi aru, Nagu mis? Kuradi asja me siin bäkke endiselt nagu jaurame ja teeme ja Midagi aru ei saa. Pilt kolmandal nädalal hakkab selginema. To late.
Õpetaja: Ee oligi. Siis keegi soovi keegi nagu andis tagasi, Kui hea oleks alustada Frondist, et see on ju nagu tuttav inimene. Ütles, et. No jah, aga meil ei ole ju back and serverit nagu mille vastu me sõnumit saadame, Siis Ma hakkasin mõtlema nagu
Õpetaja: ntr Stoplight Smart. Bear Company on teinud
Õpetaja: tegemist. On ee, niiöelda platvormiga, kes tegelikult pakub hoopis siukest, See peamiselt on mõeldud seda, et süsteemi disainerid saavad põhimõtteliselt disainida backend süsteemi, et mis teenused on
Õpetaja: panna paika urlid, panna paika sõnumid ja Nii edasi ja nii edasi ja nii edasi. Sellega saab tegelikult ehitada arhitektuuri. Vaata, et nagu mis teenused meil hakkavad süsteemis olema,
Õpetaja: teha kogu see staff valmis Ja selle vastu on väga mõine arendada. Ee, normaalsed ettevõtted teevadki. Niimoodi nad teevadki. Tegelikult ongi ettevõtted, kes teevad selle vastu,
Õpetaja: Aga üks asi, mis nende seal selles teenuses veel on, on see, et sa saad selle vähe sellest, et sa ehitad sinna ülesse, nagu et hei, mis nagu veebiteenused võiks meie Back and serveris, olla, saad sa panna ta automaatselt niiöelda ka vastama,
Õpetaja: et kui sina saadad selle Stoplight serverile sõnumi teatud Urlil teatud rajal, Siis tema automaatselt vastab sulle nii, nagu sina ütled, et sa oled ettekirjutatud vastuse, ehk siis
Õpetaja: see annab meile võlts end serveri
Õpetaja: Näete. Siin on Niukene. Meil. Muidu on. Ee, kaheksakümmend, kaheksa Vabandust, lokalost. Kaheksakümmend. Kaheksakümmend saab olema meil Ee Backendi Server, mis meie enda arvates Käib?
Õpetaja: Nüüd meie sõnumid hakkavad minema hoopis Https. Ja siis on konkreetselt see number. Need sõnumid hakkavad minema. Tegelikult Päriselt kuskile serverisse.
Õpetaja: Nii, Ja seal on juba minu poolt see ette ära tehtud, et hakkaks vastama meile ja ta Hakkaks. Siis vastama niiöelda konkreetsete näidistega.
Õpetaja: See on selles mõttes õppevahend ka. Tegelikult te ei pea seda süsteemi õppima, aga teil jääb alatiseks see teadmine, et kui te Ehitate näiteks mingit projekti?
Õpetaja: Te tahate võibolla Fronti teha? Pack I praegult ei tee. Või keegi teine teeb Pack I ja muudkui peate ootama Nende järgi, siis te tegelikult saate väga lihtsa vaevaga selles keskkonnas sisse seada. Selle vaata, et Hei,
Õpetaja: tekitab mulle niukene.
Õpetaja: Ee, veebiteenus kaldkriip, see Ja see. Ja see on ju. Ja kui mina saadan sõnumit, siis sa mulle vasta. Ee, vanasti. Kui ma Lhv s töötasin, siis meil oli ikka neid arendusi, kus ee, mobiilivennad hakkasid ühel hetkel ülivõimsalt arendama. Meil seda mobiilirakendust Lhv mobiilirakendust, mis Nüüd, ka on, võiks muudatuse saanud siia vahepeal.
Õpetaja: Aa, Ja siis oli nagu. See, et nad vajasid tegelikult teenuseid. Ja siis nad pidevalt vingusid. Vaata, et nemad väitsid, et nemad nagu Nende tööd on tuksed. Nad ootavad meie järgi. Ehk siis meie tiim. Sai keegi ülesanded, et tehke nagu Back and server Is see Ja see asi. Nad tahavad niukseid, andmeid ja nii edasi, on ju Ja see oli nagu see, et nemad ei saa oma arendust teha, et nad ei saa testida.
Õpetaja: Ja siis oli koguaeg. Need vingused nagu tõesti rekording on sees. Vä, Palun tervitused Martinitele. Ee, mobiili Martinit, kaks Martinit. Kes on mobiili arendused kogu aeg. Ee, kutsusingi mobiili Martinit, eks? Neid, eks? Tal oli koguaeg nagu ving. Vaata millal saab ja kaua saab.
Õpetaja: No täna ma mõtlen, nagu. Et kui tähendab peamine mure, oli see, et nad ei saa oma arenduskeskkonnas testida. Vaata, muidu kas asjad toimivad korrektselt
Õpetaja: ja mõned sarnasedki veel, sest tegelikult oli väga lihtne. Neil oleks seda sama tööriistanud kasutada, et meie teenus ei ole veel valmis, Palun väga, mine sinna Defineeri ära. Mis peaks liikuma. Mis sõnum? Mis? Jason?
Õpetaja: Bla blabla. Pane mingid vastused ka. Sätesta oma rakenduses, et, noh, Sõnumid lähevad selle keskkonna vastu ja saad kohe juba hakata arendama oma seda mobiili Fronti. Nagu põhimõtteliselt Teenust pole vaja. No nii, ee. Kuidas see asi välja näeb.
Õpetaja: Minul on siin. Aa, nagu ma näen kõigepealt siia, et selle see on. Nüüd Stop Light is
Õpetaja: on Niukene Url, Näete, see siin selle numbriga
Õpetaja: See on nüüd konkreetselt seotud selle projektiga, mis ma olen siis sisse pannud et kõik sõnumid, mis tulevad sellel Sellel aadressil saavad tulla sõnumid. See Id on siis arvatavasti minu mingi projekti Id, mis on automaatselt genereeritud
Õpetaja: Kui mina näiteks ma olen praegu Edit vaates.
Õpetaja: Kui tuleb sisse kett sõnum ja vaadake poolteist vlog in,
Õpetaja: siis ma saan öelda, et mina ootan sisse query Parameetreid need. On Siis urli välised parameetrid. Password ja user name.
Õpetaja: Ma olen ära defineerinud, et tasub kahel viisil vastata. Kas kõik on hästi kakssada? Kohe vaatame Staatuseid ka, või? Asjad on natukene halvasti
Õpetaja: ja mul on olemas ka siis näited. Niiöelda, kui ma tulen nüüd siia response alla,
Õpetaja: mis ta Keeleediit vaatas. Ma ikka tunnen Edit. Vaatasin minema Meedit vaatasin.
Õpetaja: Minul on ee. Minule on pandud, et. Hei, kui sina saadad Ee, sõnumi, ma Olen ära defineerinud võimalikud ee, vastused. Ma Olen öelnud, et, ee, siin
Õpetaja: Ma olen öelnud. Kui tuleb kakssada,
Õpetaja: siis ta tegelikult lihtsalt vastabki, Okei,
Õpetaja: Aga Bodys? Ta vastab siis põhimõtteliselt mulle.
Õpetaja: Kas niukse vastuse, üks, eksampl, Üks ja role name on admin või ta vastab niukse vastuse, user, Id on kaks ja Role. Name on customer, Saate aru? Ma olen siia ära defineerinud selle kõik asjad
Õpetaja: samamoodi, et kui tuleb halb vastus, Tuleb halva vastuse puhul. Mul on niukene nagu error,
Õpetaja: kus tuleb niuke sõnum Vale kasutajanimi. Parool. Error kood, üks, üks,
Õpetaja: Ma olen. See tegelikult on mõeldud selleks, et päeva lõpuks on. Tegelikult taustal on üks Niukene Suur Jason File. Nii ma panen koodi. Näete seda Kolm punkt null standard See Jason
Õpetaja: räägib kõik. See on dokumentatsioon. Põhimõtteliselt minu Back in süsteemi vastu,
Õpetaja: et tegelikult see see niiöelda ära kirjeldamine käib niimoodi Jasonis, Aga seda asja saab panna kokku ka normaalselt vormi vaates nagu niimoodi Nuppe klõbistades.
Õpetaja: Sellist asja kasutatakse päris arenduses. See tuli nagu mina, ei tea, millal ta tuli Mingi palju aastaid tagasi. See on nagu nii hea tööriist.
Õpetaja: See. On see kirjeldab süsteemi.
Õpetaja: Ja mis on parim asi Sellest on see, et siukene on tegelikult päris süsteemi. Päris süsteemis
Õpetaja: genereeritakse koodibaasi enda pealt. Sul on jaava Projekt Springpuud Sul on seal mingid Veebiteenused sa niikuinii. Kasutad seal mingeid annotatsioone, et need päriselt need veebiteenused töötaksid? Tema suudab automaatselt ise juba pool dokumentatsiooni paika panna.
Õpetaja: Mõned kohad Kus sa natuke paned? Teksti juurde? Nagu näiteks. Noh, vaatame see üldine tekst. Sa saadki panna. Teksti. Sisselogimine tagastab user. Id ja süsteemist otsitakse Username kasutajat, Kelle konto on ka aktiivne. Kui astet ei leita, visatakse viga error koodiga. Üks saate aru, Sellise asja saab päriselt lõpuks Koodi juurde panna
Õpetaja: ja see lahendab ära. Mäletate, seal kiigel, kus oli dokumentatsioon, oli lihtsalt väikene varjukene Puudus nii puu kui ka kiik. Mäletad, seda Kiike Dokumentation. Pilt oli selline. See lahendab seda muret ka,
Õpetaja: et sul on tegelikult dokumentatsioon. Elab selles mõttes otse. Koodis
Õpetaja: on koodi pealt, Enamus on genereeritud ja abistavad sõnad Sinna juurde. On kohe otse koodis. Kui midagi muudad selles loogikas, mis iganes, siis sa muudad ka nagu neid kirjeldavaid tekste ja nii edasi, et tegelikult on ta mõeldud selle. Jaoks. Aga minu jaoks meeldib see eelkõige. See, asi, et kui mina näiteks Saadan sõnumi.
Õpetaja: Sellise sõnumi login Ma panen siia password. I username I. Mida iganes. Seal pole vahet,
Õpetaja: Mina saan öelda, et ole hea. Vasta mulle, et ma olen nagu admin.
Õpetaja: Kui sa paned headerisse, et saada mulle palun selline vastus.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd sa saadad selle sõnumi,
Õpetaja: siis tema lihtsalt vastab mulle admin.
Õpetaja: Kui ma paneksin sinna kirja nagu sõnumi saatmisele, et anna mulle see Example Rain.
Õpetaja: Kui sõnumi saadad, siis ta saadab Niukse variandi. Kas te saate aru? See on võltserver.
Õpetaja: See ei ole päriselt programmeeritud. Miks see on meile vajalik, On see, et me tahame seda fronten server it arendada.
Õpetaja: Aga meil ei ole veel back and serverit. Ei ole veel seda arendanud. Kui te hakkate oma tiimi projekte tegema. Loomulikult te teete seda sellises järjekorras, et kui te teete mingisuguse, kujutage ette, Te teete ühe veebilehe ja te nüüd näete ära, et et see veebileht siin saaks toimida, on vaja Võibolla näiteks kolme sõna või
Õpetaja: Kaks sõnumit, mis toovad mingit informatsiooni ja üks sõnum näiteks mis saadab midagi süsteemile. Mingi sõnum näiteks, onju? Kui teil on see vaade olemas, siis enne, kui te hakkate frontend I arendama, siis mis oleks mõistlik. Ära. Teha Arendada ära loomulikult. Need backend teenused
Õpetaja: see. Info mida, on vaja kas. Siis saada või siis tagasi anda Vahet Pole
Õpetaja: te, Teete need teenused ära ja siis te tulete. Arendate Fronti. Vaata, teil ei ole seda probleemi. Vaata, on ju? Aga täna me tahame õppida Fronti
Õpetaja: õppida programist läbi Fronti.
Õpetaja: Ee, me ei taha veel seda kasutada, aga meil peab keegi olema. Kes meie sõnumitele vastab. Kas siin on Küsimusi
Õpetaja: ei ole võlts. Back and server.
Õpetaja: No kui vaadata ka pui, usu, siis. Ee, näete. Tema paneb lõpuks kokku
Õpetaja: Aa, vaikimisi. Ta saadab vist selle. Aa, mis iganes. Näete seda urli siin.
Õpetaja: Ja mis kaasa peab minema,
Õpetaja: siis ta ütles, et Oota korra. Ma vaatan, kas ta C urlina ei paku mulle, seda,
Õpetaja: mida aktsiast, nagu ta on.
Õpetaja: Mis ta ära võetab?
Õpetaja: Pastard põhimõttel.
Õpetaja: No nüüd tuli
Õpetaja: praegu, tema ütleb, et Kui sina saadad niukse. Aa, kus on user? Ja need kõik? Ma ei saa aru.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma pean midagi panema. Aa, w w, w, Vot nii, kohe võtame selle hurdi pilvasteks.
Õpetaja: Näete seda urli siin, kuni esimese niiöelda selle kaldkriipsuni. See on serveri aadress Nüüd siit, kuni
Õpetaja: küsimärgini on rada, mäletate? Küsi Rada? Küsimärk lõpetab raja
Õpetaja: nüüd meie Tegelikult see Niiöelda. Päris rada on see ülejäänud rada? On see nende enda serveri Sisene rada. Vaata, et saaks aru, mis on vaja teha
Õpetaja: meie põhimõtteliselt. Tegelikult saadame kõik sõnumid, mis lähevad, kui ma ütleks Enterprad kõik sõnumid. Mis ma saadan, lähevad getsõnumina. Rada on siis ka enda. Nagu. Ja vaadake peale küsimärki tulevad rajaparameetrid nimelised parameetrid. Username läheb väärtusega Pbb
Õpetaja: and Password läheb väärtusega. Aa, see on see, et me saame anda mingisuguse sisendi
Õpetaja: oma serverile. Ja hetkel on see sellise lahendusega tehtud, kui ma Vajutan Brad City entrit.
Õpetaja: Kas mul tuli vastus?
Õpetaja: See on ju täpselt see sama asi. Vaata,
Õpetaja: me saatsime lihtsalt brauseris sõnumi, on ju? Nii?
Õpetaja: Ja tema vastas.
Õpetaja: Kui ma võtan näiteks selle sama sõnumi, võtan näiteks Postmani lahti.
Õpetaja: Mis on siis programm,
Õpetaja: milles on nagu mõnus, nagu alati, Erinevaid sõnumeid, mida tahad saata? See on testimiseks valdavalt mõeldud. Tahad testida midagi?
Õpetaja: Mul on siin igasugused projektid asjad. Ma ütlen, et hei, uus Sõnum, sõnum.
Õpetaja: Aga kohe räägime nendest. Ka. Vaata, et siin on erinevad meetodid. Get Post, Putch Delete. Need on peamised
Õpetaja: Mina Ütlen kett, sõnum, Panen urli.
Õpetaja: Tema siit võtab sellest urli seest ise välja. Näete Params nimelised. Parameetri username. Vaata, ma panen siia.
Õpetaja: Ccc Panen. Sellele
Õpetaja: Näete, kuidas Need Siin muutuvad, on ju Need on raja niiöelda Välised. Need ei ole osa rajast.
Õpetaja: Vaata, siin sees on ka on ka rajasisesed muutuvad. Räägime nendest hiljem. Need on rajavälised. Vaata, rada lõppeb siin. Ära küsimärgiga. Ma ei saa kuidagi suuremaks teha. Kui ma saadan siit selle sõnumi,
Õpetaja: Siis ma saan Jason I vastu, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ehk siis täpselt see asi, mis ma siin rääkisin.
Õpetaja: Saadad Bosveni, aga lihtsalt meie saadame kogu Aeg Stop Light Ile sõnumeid.
Õpetaja: Nii on siin kohal küsimusi.
Õpetaja: Ei, et kui sul on ainult üks, kuni üks projekt on täiesti tasuta, saab Kes iganes seda regada ja kasutada. Aga niipea kui ta teiste eest. Ta ütleb, et kahjuks ei,
Õpetaja: aga muidugi alati on võimalik Ee, import, eksport Ja vahetad ühe projekti teise vastu. Ja toimetad niimoodi ka, Kui teil mitu kontot nagu enamus teil. Kas kõigil, kas teil kõigil on Käsi püsti, kellel on vähemalt kaks emaili aadressi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd käsi püsti, kellest Kellel üks nendest on prügi jaoks.
Õpetaja: Ahah, aga mille jaoks siis teistel on kaks armukesed või Mis Teine nagu
Õpetaja: mul on siin Annaga Näiteks nagu koos Gmail, et nagu seal on kõik mingid asjad, mis on Nagu sünditud. Ja siis mul on eraldi hotmail, kus on kirjad.
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlengi. Vaata, et see on imeline. Kaval mõte ju. Vaata miks maksta rohkem. Vaata, et mina teeks samamoodi.
Õpetaja: Aa, siis ta küsib vaja Verification It on ju ka? Vaata, jah,
Õpetaja: no nii, mõte. Ee, nii, Ee, Et selles mõttes, et ee. Saab mitut kontot teha ka kui vaja. Ee, Nüüd, kui me tuleme selle progemise juurde, siis, kui te, teete oma projekti lahti või? No tegelikult, see on vaatamise koht
Õpetaja: siin all. Aa, meil on läbi viite. On see projekt installitud. See projekt on tehtud. Ärge küsige. See on lihtsalt käsurea Teema.
Õpetaja: Siin on nagu kogu serveri konfig.
Õpetaja: Kui see lahti teha ja jõuate niisugusesse sektsiooni nagu server Ja Proxy,
Õpetaja: siis seal on Niukene rida.
Õpetaja: Ja see rida tähendab nagu seda. Vaata, et, ee, ee. Meie saadame sõnumi,
Õpetaja: Kui meile tuleb Ee Me tahame enda. Ütleme niimoodi hästi pikalt. Kui meil endal tuleb nagu meie serverisse tuleb sõnum, millele ei ole kandidaati, siis ta saadab selle edasi. See on niuke. Hästi tehniline, aga põhimõtteliselt. Kas te näete, et siin on juba põhimõtteliselt see urli osa olemas.
Õpetaja: Kui me läheme, vaatame Seda kohta on ju, et kui sina tahad saata ee, sõnumit,
Õpetaja: siis peab olema ees selline osa. Vaata, see on nüüd tegelikult nende Stoplight I server koos nende rajaga.
Õpetaja: Meil on siia see projekti ära golfitud, mis on välja kommenteeritud, on lokal Ost kaheksa kaheksakümmend,
Õpetaja: mis on praegult Hetkel sees on see ülemine rida. See on aktiivne rida. Kui me jõuame oma arendusega nii kaugele, et me teeme Frondis asjad ära, hakkame Backendi arendama, Siis me tuleme siia ja teeme niiöelda.
Õpetaja: Et tegelikult, kui meie frontend tahab saada andmeid, siis ta saadab selle hoopis kaheksakümmend kaheksakümmend, vastu, mis on meie enda päris server. Saate ma tõesti aru? Üks hetk, Switch. Ime.
Õpetaja: Praegult peab täpselt nii olema.
Õpetaja: Kõik sõnumid, mis hakkavad teele minema lähevad. Tegelikult selle urli vastu.
Õpetaja: Mis iganes Hurt tuleb Kaldkriips, login algus on see,
Õpetaja: Kas siin on kellegil küsimusi, et me saadame sõnumit. Tegelikult võlts. Te kipute ära unustama Mingil põhjusel ka. Ja mõtlete, et. Oot, oot, aga see ei tööta. Aga Kuidas ma teistmoodi, see on kõik võlts praegult. Ma mõtlen, et päris funktsionaalsusi Me saame testida juba praegu ja proovida ja mängida ja
Õpetaja: ja kunagi hakkame ükshaaval niimoodi neid teenuseid arendama välja. Backendis. Õpime. Backendi, See on see plaan.
Õpetaja: No see ongi nüüd siis. Ee. Järgmine. Lessen.
Õpetaja: Ei, Meie meie praegult praegult Me tahame. Me tahamegi hakata seda sõnumit saatma,
Õpetaja: aga hetkel ta lihtsalt teeb alert. Tere, maailm on nii
Õpetaja: Okei, Aa, enne kui me me Siin me selle võib korra tinglikult ära muuta. Vaata, et saadame sõnumi.
Õpetaja: Back end I. Nii, see on plaan.
Õpetaja: Minu küsimus on, kui me Vaatame,
Õpetaja: millal ee, millal andmete päring Back and serverilt logi sisse vajutamisel, mis on esimene punkt
Õpetaja: välja.
Õpetaja: Ja kui kumbki väline jäänud täitmata, siis
Õpetaja: Nii siis on. Vaata, näete, siin on alert. Danger. Niukene punkt. Voe niukene. Raamid ja asjad
Õpetaja: loo selle jaoks eraldi komponent Alert, mis võtab sisse. Propsi Message.
Õpetaja: Kui message on tühi tühi Strings I siis alerti ei kuvata. Kui on mingi sisu, siis kuvatakse Alerti, nüüd me tahaksime tegeleda. Kõigepealt enne kui me üldse sõnumi saadame. Selle osaga.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui me hakkame seda nuppu kogu aeg vajutama siis see alert muudkui tuleb ette. Ma teeks niimoodi. Ma kommenteeriks selle välja. Niimoodi
Õpetaja: panete Kakssada Javascriptis ja Javas on niimoodi, et kaks kaldkriipsu ka kommenteerid välja, aga kui Teil on juba see shortcut olemas. Siis lihtsalt klikkige sinna Reale ja control Shift Seitse või siis kaldkriips. Kontrol kaldkriips, kuidas iganes,
Õpetaja: ee, nii et see muidu hakkab kogu aeg tulema. Meile Nüüd
Õpetaja: see see on siin. Ee, see on siin vi vihje.
Õpetaja: Kui kumbki välju on jäänud Täitmata jah. If
Õpetaja: nüüd ongi. Ma. Mäletate, ma Rääkisin Ärge unusta ära. Programmeerimine juhtimine on If. Lausetega.
Õpetaja: Mine seda teed pidi või teistpidi.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: Siis mina küsin nüüd teilt, et, ee, Kui meil True False username ja on hetkel seotud nende kahe boksiga Siit
Õpetaja: on, on ju siis Kas vastab tõele, et nüüd siin koodis? Me Siis saame põhimõtteliselt vaadata, et. Kuule,
Õpetaja: kui need mõlemad on täidetud,
Õpetaja: siis võib ainult minna edasi, See on meie plaan teisel juhul. Viska viga. Vaata, ee, kui me teeme If lauseid, kui me teeme If lauseid ja tegelikult, siin on Ju If Else,
Õpetaja: Sest et kui kõik on hästi, saada sõnum vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Kui mitte, siis viska kuva vea teadet. See on ju If Else,
Õpetaja: Siis minu soovitus on alati see, et ee, teha. Pigem niimoodi. Vaata, see positiivne asi on seal selles üleval, selles If blokis ja Erin, vaata, et nagu, Oi midagi valesti, on seal Else blokis. Sest see tundub loogiline.
Õpetaja: See tundub loogiline, et me ei taha nagu negatiivset asja ennem otsida. Kuigi tegelikult idee. Just Seda me otsimegi, Et nagu siin kontekstis. Meil ei ole ju mõtet saata. Ära seda sõnumit kliendile Kui ei ole pointi seda saata, sest kasutaja pole veel nagu nõuete kohaselt seda vormi täitnud, on nii?
Õpetaja: Siis. Ee. Mina. Mina nagu ikkagi. Selles mõttes teeksin Else nagu bloki niimoodi. Et kui kõik on hästi, siis nagu saadame sõnumi ja Else, midagi ei ole vaja manageerida,
Õpetaja: Okei, No aga hakkame seda If lauset ehitama.
Õpetaja: If, oota.
Õpetaja: Kui vaid oleks,
Õpetaja: teeme selle If lause juba ära. Ee, kuidas ma tegin seda, Ma Lihtsalt kirjutasin ka. Nüüd onju, et
Õpetaja: ta teeb juba selle sulud ära. No ma panen lihtsalt praegu lihtsalt truu siia. Ette. Vaata, Control Shift Enter, mida ta teeb? Ta teeb automaatselt selle If bloki lõpu ära ja ja teeb ka siia need loogilised sulud.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi, on nii? Ma Võin siia ruumi jätta ja tegelikult teha ka nüüd else ära.
Õpetaja: Elsa. Tab ja siin jälle Control Shift enter.
Õpetaja: Ärge hakake neid loogilisi sulgusi otsima kuskilt Aa, nendest
Õpetaja: Ee ülevalt nuppudest. Mingi, mis on Control alt ja seitse. Ja Jumal teab, mis iganes need loogilise sulgeda Sa oskab auto compliitida. Ära
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd. Meie peame mõtlema, et Mis Conditionil me saame sõnumit saata.
Õpetaja: Mm, midagi. Midagi. Kohe seda teemegi. Aga nüüd on Selline asi, et. Ee. Siin tuleb nüüd selle. Ee, väikene. Nüüd vimka tuleb sisse.
Õpetaja: Kui me siin üleval template osas saame, viidata nendele muutujatele Lihtsalt Otse öeldes, username
Õpetaja: Nüüd see on. Jätke lihtsalt meelde. Nüüd ainult siin. Script blokis. Ainult script blokis siin all me peame ütlema ette, sõna,
Õpetaja: et viidata databloki muutujatele ja ma kohe räägin, miks.
Õpetaja: Kujutame ette. See on vaatamise koht. Kujutame ette, et mina tahan käivet käivitada, seda Login meetodit kuskilt, onju
Õpetaja: Näiteks, aga ma tahan. Ma ei taha seda teha. Aga ma tahan öelda, et ma kir et mul on siin Defineeritud niukene muutuja nagu user Name.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma käivitan meetodi, siis ma annan kaasa mingi väärtuse.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui ma tahaksin siit et näe, Käivita login.
Õpetaja: Ma nagu näitan seda Käivitan Login
Õpetaja: Noh, see nüüd. See ei ole nüüd õige koht. Vaata, ma ei saa siit kohast käivitada otse. Vaata, on ju? Aga mõte on nagu see, et mina. Tahaks öelda, et käivita loo kinni ja anna kaasa. Rain saate, ma tast aru. See on ju meetod,
Õpetaja: et mul peab niuke võimalus igal juhul jääma. Aga kui mina oleksin praegult siin nüüd username ja kirjutaks nad siia. Vaata, et hei. Kui username.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, võrdub võrdub. Näiteks. Aa, tühik. Ärge seda ka kirjutage. Siis Kuidas Kuidas ta nüüd saab aru, kas ma mõtlen nüüd seda? Username I. Mis on see sildikene või see sildikene?
Õpetaja: Väga, lihtsalt niimoodi saab aru, kui sa paned selle, Kas on niimoodi, et see on valge?
Õpetaja: Ja see on valge?
Õpetaja: Kui ma kirjutan siia koodiploki näiteks. Ja niimoodi see on vaatamise koht. This
Õpetaja: Punkt username siis Mis värvi tema on?
Õpetaja: Lilla Vot just selle jaoks, et just ongi vajalik. Just selle jaoks ongi vajalik et meil, siin Koodiplokis. Selles kohalikus koodipleki Blokis võib juba olla üks sildikene. Username?
Õpetaja: Kuidas me siis. Ja me ei taha teha niimoodi, et me hakkame seal üleval kirjutama mingi. Ja, no mingeid et oleks kaks erinevat nime. Ei, Ei, ei, see on nagu, põhimõtteliselt objekti muutuja.
Õpetaja: Kui setteriga tahad väärtustada, Vaadake setter meetodi. Siis on, niimoodi. Et sul tuleb. Käivitatakse meetod. Set first, Name. Siis sa võtad String First Name
Õpetaja: Üleval on muutuja, First name. Ja siis lihtsalt öeldakse all koodiplokis, et see ülemine this first name võrdub. First name, mis tuleb sisse Kui meetod jaavast ees siis Oleks kohe nagu
Õpetaja: teeme ruttu. Siin Chat iga.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen. Ee, ruttu.
Õpetaja: Ee, ruttu.
Õpetaja: Üks kiire jaava seter.
Õpetaja: Meetodi näide
Õpetaja: Nii on car, ja Siin on vä. Selle objektiga käib kaasas väärtusmudel, String.
Õpetaja: Kuna ta on Private, Siis kui mul on see objekt kuskilt olemas, Vaata, on ju Siis ma ei saa. Öelda näiteks muuta nimi. Car punkt model. Sest et seda välja sa ei saa väljaspoolt kuidagi katsuda.
Õpetaja: Küll ma saan öelda, Car punkt Z mudeli anda mingisuguse väärtuse. Nüüd, Vaadake see on see, põhimõtteliselt siin. Need kaks.
Õpetaja: Ja see dish mudel viitab. Sellele on täpselt Sama süsteem.
Õpetaja: Me peame kuidagi saama eristada kohalikke muutujaid
Õpetaja: ja need, mis on objekti muutajad
Õpetaja: jaavas. Siin on täpselt sama asi. Siin on Lihtsalt seda on vaja eristada. Sellest.
Õpetaja: Sellel on küsimusi
Õpetaja: ei ole. No me saame seda veel harjutada. Ainuke asi, mis te peate praegult meeles hoidma, on lihtsalt see, et iga kord, Iga Jumala. Kord, kui te olete Scriptis, siis te peate viitama nendele ülevalt templeidest. Eeldatakse, et nendega me Kogu aeg tahamegi suhelda.
Õpetaja: Siin Template osas ei saa olla mingeid muutujaid. Ma siin ei saa kirjutada. Nagu mingi hei muutuja.
Õpetaja: See on See on Html. Siin ma ei saa, See ei ole kood. See ei ole kood siia. Ma ei saa luua uut uut muutujat,
Õpetaja: saate aru Siin ei ole Nagu seda segadust. Kui ma. Nagu hiljem, nagu ütlen, ma ütlen, Oletame, et saaks siia. Vaata, et oletame, et ma Ütlen ka siin
Õpetaja: Uus muutuja. Lihtsalt Atml is. Noh, kui ma nüüd siin viitan, username, et kas ma mõtlen seda või ma mõtlen seda,
Õpetaja: Sest et siin ei saa niikuinii niukest asja teha. Siia, Ärge toppige neid tisse.
Õpetaja: Siin ei ole vaja Tehniliselt ta vist isegi töötab, aga kindel. Ei, mida pole vaja, Pole vaja, on ju
Õpetaja: Siin Ei ole segadust.
Õpetaja: See asi suudab niikuinii ainult nende asjadega siin communicate Ida, aga Siin all ei ole sama. Case, Ma teen siia. Lihtsalt võrdub Rain.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd on küsimus, et mida ma siin kontrollin,
Õpetaja: Ma kontrollin selle Sisu või? Ma tahan öelda, et
Õpetaja: kes käib. Noh, saate aru.
Õpetaja: Sinu all Scriptis on alati küsimus, millest sa jääpid, Vend, Kas sa räägid sellest muutujast. Või sa räägid sellest muutujast,
Õpetaja: siis koodis. Sa alati ütled vis, siis ta saab aru. Sa mõtled seda ja sa värvi järgi Näed kohe ära. Kui lilla ei ole,
Õpetaja: siis siis sellest databloki muutujest sa ei räägi Igal juhul ma ei tea, millest sai äpid, Noh, Kui ma nüüd kirjutan nad praegu koodi niimoodi siin.
Õpetaja: Ja kui username võrdub tühjus,
Õpetaja: siis ta tõmbab üldse joone alla. Ta ütleb et kuule, Niukest Ee, muutujat ei ole.
Õpetaja: Ma vajutan selle peale. Näed, tegi seda ülesemuutaja nime, on ta. Isegi kui sa unustad tissi ära ja siis Ta on valge ja ta veel allajoonitud. Ka. Ta ei saa aru, millest sa räägid. Siin vend
Õpetaja: lilla. Ta ei ole datablokiga, see sellest Temale sa ei viita.
Õpetaja: Paned siia ette?
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd juba saab aru, millest sa räägid.
Õpetaja: Okei, see mõte jookseb teil kokku, vaata või endal ka veel. Vahel nagu tuleb, et hakkad põhiline mure on see, et sa hakkad siin koodis kohe kirjutama. Nii ma lahen Scriptis Neid Sa Viitad ja kirjutad nendele asjadele, mida pole olemas. Muidugi, mis võiks. Promptida oleneb? Kuidas koodi kirjutad? Kui Sa, kirjutad user name
Õpetaja: kas ta pakub mulle. Vaata, et ma saaks autot abiga. Compliiti vä
Õpetaja: ei paku See juba peaks olema hint. Hint, hint, hint. Aa, Copy. Based. Juba kirjutad Minult järgi. Vaata, unustad ise eest ära. Ei, ma ei viitsi kirjutada neid asju välja. Kui kirjutad tiss,
Õpetaja: punkt juba pakub. Isegi Paned selle U tähe ära pakub.
Õpetaja: Noh, Sk. Võibolla veel tab olemas Lilla ka,
Õpetaja: et siin peab, aga ülevale ei, pea, sest, et see probleem on See, et siin võib olla
Õpetaja: koodis, võib endas olla. Ka meil on vajadus, et. Noh, pigem. Ta tuleb parameetrina sisse.
Õpetaja: Siis on nagu see, Et millest, millest sa räägid? Me peame kuidagi saama nüüd eristada. Okei, mida me siis selle username? Iga tahame vaadata. Vaata, et meil on Niimoodi, et siin on sada sõnum
Õpetaja: Ta peab lille olema. Jah,
Õpetaja: Ta peab lille olema, Sest et siin me tahame näha, seda, mis on seotud selle kastiga. Näe, tõmbame kõik ülejäänud jama kokku. Meil on siin see username. Me tahame viidata, et mis iganes seal kastis on,
Õpetaja: millal saab saata sõnumi.
Õpetaja: Kui username.
Õpetaja: Kuidas me ütleme, on täidetud ja siis niimoodi kahjuks ei saa kahjuks programmeerimisest. No tehniliselt võttes tegelikult see see on nüüd lühiviis. Ma ei tea, kas ma teen teiega seda või mitte. Seda ta nüüd võtab seda. Vaata, kas on tühi või ei Ole
Õpetaja: ee. Võrdusmärki siis.
Õpetaja: Ja kaks kulud.
Õpetaja: Mis asja? Kaks võrdlusmärki Aga siis on see, et kui username on tühi,
Õpetaja: et siis saadame sõnumi Või pole. Ju siis midagi? Pole? Vist eriti nagu võimalik sisse logida, kui.
Õpetaja: Ahaa, vaata, Nüüd on see. Mäletad? Ee, inversioon. Tagurpidi keeramine jutumärgiga,
Õpetaja: Nüüd selline asi töötab ka See ei ole punane joon. See on kollane joon ja kollane pirn.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate, mis asi siin on?
Õpetaja: See nüüd on Jaava script.
Õpetaja: Jaovascripti ei ole ju tüüpidega ära defineeritud. Tüüpe pole.
Õpetaja: Siin on väga suur vahe. Vaata see, et kas me Ütleme, et kas on tühi väärtus. Vaata, on ju või see on ka vaadatakse tüüpi.
Õpetaja: Ee jaavas ei ole võrdlus. Ütleme, kui ma tahaks vaadata Kas on tühi? Tühi Streng jaavas oleks umbes niimoodi,
Õpetaja: Aga on veel kolmas võrdusmärk ka. Nende kahe erinevus on see et vaadatakse, et Mõlemad pooled tüübi mõttes on ka võrdsed, mitte ei vaadata sisu. Vaata, oletame, et me vaataks mingit numbrit.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen, vaataks, et kas võrdub Kaks kui ühel pool on String
Õpetaja: kaks. No üks. Ütleme parem. See on parem näide, kuna on juba ees. Me saame vaadata seda. Vaata, Ütleme niimoodi. Ma näitan siit hoopis teistmoodi. Ee, ärme võta nagu Muutuja Sisu
Õpetaja: siin On küsimus. See, et kas ta praegu on, miks Ta Force on?
Õpetaja: Jah, et lisaks sisule ta kontrollib. Praegu. Ta ei tuleks siia sisse sellepärast, et kolme sellega Me ütleme, et vaata neid väärtusi, Aga kolmas ütleb, et vaata tüüpi ka
Õpetaja: praegu. Ta ei tuleks siia sisse sellepärast, et me ütleme, et kas siin, Ee, mõlemad pooled on Number üks ei ole ju ainukene asi, Kus ta oleks truu, oleks, saaks ta niimoodi olla praegu,
Õpetaja: aga see ei ole. Vaata, see on Siis String.
Õpetaja: Juhul, kui meil oleks kahe võrdusmärgiga nüüd java script taustal, proovib need mõlemad pooled teha samaks tüübiks,
Õpetaja: Ta proovib võtta seda teha seda stringiks või teist poolt. Proovib teha numbriks. Vahet pole, ta Põhimõtteliselt üritab ise selle Conversion I ära teha ja siis vaadata, kas ta Kas sisuliselt on siis sama väärtus Praegu Ta tuleks siia sisse, sest et ta suudab teha selle stringi üks numbriks, üks
Õpetaja: ja siis ta tuleks siia truusse. Aga meie loomulikult. Jaavascriptis Soovime ikka hoida asja hoida võimalikult täpsena. Me alati kasutame seda võimalust, et me kasutame kolme
Õpetaja: ee, seda niiöelda märki. Ja kui me nüüd tahame panna inversiooni et tagurpidi, siis me ei. Tule. Pane siia juurde veel ühte sümbolit, vaid see Siin
Õpetaja: kolmas ongi. Kui praegult võtad niimoodi ära näed, siis ta ütlebki. Hakkab midagi. Hakkab taipida, siis jahuma. Vaadake,
Õpetaja: comparis on üks Üks meid kaasa
Õpetaja: tüüpi. Võibolla tüübiga võib tekkida probleeme, et niimoodi me kontrolliksime, et Ei, ei võrdu. Siin ees oli dis punkt. User name.
Õpetaja: Ei, võrdu.
Õpetaja: Mis asi ei võrdu tühjus?
Õpetaja: Nii, kui see username ei ole tühi, siis vähemalt, Mis puudutab username Vist on nagu fine,
Õpetaja: aga me ei saa, kui kasutaja täidab ära ainult siin oma selle username.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma lähen korra siia tagasi.
Õpetaja: Kui ta kasutab selle ära, vaata siis kas Ta saaks. Login I juba teha
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et seda oleks ka vaja kontrollida, on ju? Meil ei ole mõtet Backendi saata ilma Paroolita sõnumit,
Õpetaja: Siis on
Õpetaja: vot and and siis Me liidame. Noh, kellel oli see käsi? Püsti? Kellel oli see and ja lutsikal operators oli. Noh, näed, Aadam tõstis käe. Selle ma peaks teadma.
Õpetaja: Mõlemad pooled võrdsed. Ainult siis andru on. Nii
Õpetaja: et me tahame vaadata seda, et ka ei ole tühi.
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele? Ainult siis on Point I saata sõnumid,
Õpetaja: Nüüd praegu on ainult siin paar. Aa, siin on ainult paar tingimust, aga Kujutame sellegi poolest ette, kui ma tulen siia meetodisse. Nüüd on see, et pange see müts pähe. Vaata, et mina üldse ei ole seda koodi kirjutanud.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tulen siia loo kinni ja tulen umbes siia kohta, siis mis tahad. Kas korraks tõmbab protsessori kumisema?
Õpetaja: Ärgu nüüd pange See müts Bad ei ole seda koodi kirjutanud. Me ei ole seda arutanud.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt tuled, Vaatad, login.
Õpetaja: Okei, ma võin öelda, see on veel Küllaltki loetav asi. Vaata, mis on tahtnud, teha, Aga niipea, kui me tunneme ja minu meelest me võiks seda kohe praegult teha, on, see et
Õpetaja: et niipea, kui see asi hakkab natukene nagu võtab nagu süvenemist aega Ja siin on nagu minu Ja niiöelda Cloud i Cloud I Nagu arvamused Natukene, nagu lähevad lahku, Mina teeks sellest asjast juba praegult abimeetodi.
Õpetaja: Ma teeks meetodid, mis tagastab Prouway Falls
Õpetaja: ja kogu see osa Olekski põhimõtteliselt returnis nii öelda. Kas vastab tõele praegult? See asi rehkendub Trucks või False. No muidu If Lause ei töötagi
Õpetaja: see. Pea see Ei saa olla nagu see, et siin on. Ma ei tea, ma teen niimoodi, nagu et siin on. Lihtsalt Ma ei tea, kümme if kümme. No. Mis ei, siin on mingi? Võrdlust pole Lihtsalt väärtust see. Peab rehkenduma
Õpetaja: kuidas. Mina selle teeksin On see? Et, ee Mina. Teeks Eraldi meetodi
Õpetaja: selle nüüd on hästi tähtis. Puulerite puhul puhud on hästi. Tähtis, et nad on Statement Id
Õpetaja: Ee, Puulöönide puhul on tähtis, et See Kas muutuja nimi või Meetode nimi. Vahet pole,
Õpetaja: peab alati olema statement. Mitte kunagi päriselt. Küsi küsimus, nagu, kas on kõik välja täidetud
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et kui me loeksime praegu, siis ma korra panen selle muuta lihtsalt tasemele.
Õpetaja: Ma panen korra. Kujutage ette, et see on oleks muutuja.
Õpetaja: Aa on muutuja. No ma. Okei. Ma korra isegi teen muutujaks selle. See on vaatamise koht. Selekteeri praegult selle teksti ja ütlen, et tee Sellest sinisest osast ma. Kas ta on? Ma saaks ka panna refaktor. Aa, Introduce Variablack Control Altv. On? Ju? Aa, niimoodi siit käsitsi, aga Ma ütlen, et tee sellest korra muutuja. Lihtsalt see on vaatamise koht.
Õpetaja: Tema teeb mingisuguse muute. Ma saan selle nime panna, kui ma paneksin selle küsimuse vormis. Näiteks are all.
Õpetaja: Four Aa forum fields With
Õpetaja: korrekt Input no. See oleks hästi pikalt ma. Elu sees ei paneks ma Kujutame ette, kui ma juba praegu näeksin seda lauset, siis oleks natuke parem. Aga see ei mängi nüüd kokku selle sõnaga If
Õpetaja: kui With Correct Input ta. Ta ei sobi kokku sellepärast, et see nimi on küsivas vormis.
Õpetaja: Aga kui ta oleks statement vormis nii nagu peabki olema, Siis ta mängib selle If iga juba päris hästi kokku, et kui ma refaktureeriks selle ära.
Õpetaja: Ee, is form.
Õpetaja: Mm korra. Ma Võibolla ma ei mäleta, mis muude nime võiksin kasutada siin natuke korra. Ma mõtlen ka,
Õpetaja: Ma tahaks juba praegu teha. Vaata, nagu seda, niimoodi. Et ta Oleks hästi nagu geneeriline, et me saaksime edaspidi Kasutada sama lähenemist
Õpetaja: nagu selles mõttes, et nagu need sõnad nagu haakub siit ka mujal vaata. On ju
Õpetaja: Palun,
Õpetaja: See on statement. Kui te mõtlete sellele lausele lausele, siis ta ütleb all Form feels
Õpetaja: with correct import. No mulle väga, Ei meeldi see pikk ja loisav. Aga mõtle, saate aru. See on statement hüüumärgiga.
Õpetaja: Kui sa nüüd loed If ja mõtled sisu den If All for Feels.
Õpetaja: Paneme tegusõna juurde. Ma mõtlesin, et midagi on puudu.
Õpetaja: All. Form Fields Arvid. Correct Import kas. See Kõnetab teid
Õpetaja: kui, te Nüüd vaatate seda. Lause If all form for it correct input, vend. Vaata, mõelge juba selles. Oled ven?
Õpetaja: Kas see kõnetab normaalselt, nagu juba, Vaata sellepärast, et see puul ongi. Ta peab olemagi nagu selles mõttes. Statement, Millele sa saad öelda? Jah või ei, sellepärast, et ta tavaliselt ongi If Statement I sees.
Õpetaja: Ja kui sa If Statement i sees loed seda statement It. Sest et seal, sa paned lõhna sõna juurde, Kui
Õpetaja: kui see on tõde, siis teeb,
Õpetaja: et ee, on alati statement vormis, nagu ta nagu state ib midagi,
Õpetaja: bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. Sellepärast, et kui sa paned If
Õpetaja: või kasiino online kasiino, saate aru, Sa mängid kokku.
Õpetaja: No kui me praegu vaatame seda, siis täpselt nii teeb. Kas vastab tõele, et siin on muutuja? Lihtsalt, onju. Kui te vaatate praegult seda paremat poolt, siis mis siin toimub? Siin on võrdlus kahe asja vahel. See asi siin saab ainult rehkenduda,
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: Siin ongi see validatsioon, mida ma ei tahaks teha loomulikult. See,
Õpetaja: et siin oleks mingisugune muutuja selles koodilõigus Sest ta. Siis on muutuja, mis on kohe siin allkasutatud ühe korra. Aga mida sellest võiks teha on hoopis See, et me teeme sellest eraldi meetodi.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et meetodile saab anda nime vastab tõele Meetodile, saab anda nime
Õpetaja: Aa, sellele meetodile isegi tuleb parameetreid Sellepärast, et see koodilõik saab kust iga saate aru, siia alla tuleb alla. Tahame teha ühte niukest meetodit, mis on lihtsalt retöörlauses Retöörlauses on selline koodilõik
Õpetaja: ta tagastab. See on meie plaan
Õpetaja: Ja siis me saame niimoodi, et meil on siin nagu normaalne mingisugune meetod, Ma panen Esialgu praegu nii täpselt nagu me panime. Aga nüüd on see asi ka, et need on erinevad moodused, kuidas Seda, teha. Me võime käsitsi selle meetodi ise teha.
Õpetaja: Aga me võime ka kasutada Mina Kasutaks. Loomulikult jaavas. See toimib täiesti perfektselt. Siin on väikene konksu veel juures, et Kuhu Kurat see meetod peab minema?
Õpetaja: Ta saab tegelikult ka siia. Script Tagg idesse minna. Siia vahele, kuskile
Õpetaja: Ee, ta saab siia meetodi blokki minna
Õpetaja: idee järgi. See on nagu väga veider. Ta saab meetodi. Saab Defini ühe funktsiooni sisse, saab defineerida teise funktsiooni. No seda ei pea kunagi kasutama. Nagu, et Point on see, et kuhu sa pead minema. See on ju kaasa tegemise koht. Kas teil praegu see on? Ees,
Õpetaja: Nii ütleme. Me tahame sellest. Ja tobe asi on see, et ma. Tehke juba natukene space siia niimoodi ette. Vaata, ta kahjuks ei paku meile sellist vaikimisi, kui ta teeb selle meetodi, mis ta teeb? Kurat, ma korra näiteks Teen siia mingi meetoodi
Õpetaja: nimi.
Õpetaja: Surud keha, mis ta teeb. Ma vihkan seda. Ta teeb mingisuguse meetodi, Aga ta topib selle niimoodi kahjuks ette
Õpetaja: ette ja ei jäta isegi
Õpetaja: ei jää, et isegi reavahetust, et natukene peab jälgima. Aga see on ka väga väikene asi. Kui me nüüd võtame nagu selle koodilõigu siit,
Õpetaja: teeme siniseks. Noh, tehke Hiirega näiteks.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd, selle asemel, et muutu. Et ekstraktide. Me ütleme, et. Kuule, tee see koodilõik lihtsalt meetodiks
Õpetaja: ja pange tähele Return ta Ta lihtsalt ret. Kuna ta on seal If Lause, vahel siis ta saab aru, et siia peab tulema True või False. Ta teeb sellise meetodi, mis Teeb Return Statement I ka. Ja selle sama koodi sinna panebki, kui te vajutate nüüd.
Õpetaja: Noh, M, kohe vaata, aga mina näitan et kui ma panen ka siia peale refaktor või kasutan seda sama pirnikest korra siin. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: mis ta pakub. Refaktor, ekstrakt, meetod.
Õpetaja: Võta siit Koodist välja Koodilõik, ekstrakt. Võta ta välja. Tee sellest eraldi meetod ja kutsu siin selles kohas seda meetodit välja. Thats what it is
Õpetaja: m. Ja nüüd on see, et. Ee, pange tähele. Vaata, kui ma siit ülevalt hakkan pihta ja näete, kuidas ma ei saa näidata vaadata siin Korraks tilbendab ja siin tilbendab.
Õpetaja: Näete seda? Ta näitab, et kuhu sa tahad seda meetodit panna. Top level on kuhugi script i ülesse, aga väljapoole nii öelda neid. Voe seda neid.
Õpetaja: Teine variant. Ta pakub, et pane selle login meetodi ülesse, on ju nii nagu ma rääkisin. Pane sinna tema ette. Ja viimane on see, et pane selle hoopis siia meetodi sisse. Veel üks meetod.
Õpetaja: Meie teeme alati top level ja üks samm alla. Ehk Siis pane see meetodi blokki. Kas ta on meetodi bloki sees? Vaadake rida. Nelikümmend kaks on ju Metsastusblokk algab. Kas ta on selle sees?
Õpetaja: Ta Paneb selle meetodi ette. Mulle meeldiks, ta paneks selle login meetodi järgi. Kahjuks mõni ei saa teda survestada, aga ma Saan käsitsi tõsta, kui sa vajutad nüüd entrit.
Õpetaja: Nüüd nüüd ta seisab siin. Meetodi nime peal ja ütleb, et et ta kutsub välja siin ees olevad meetodid. Getp. Praegu ta ei tea, lihtsalt. Ta ei oska praegu ise nagu genereerida. Mis selle meetodi nimi võiks olla?
Õpetaja: Nüüd siia Meie võime panna. Vaata, Forum Fields
Õpetaja: Are ma. Arvan et, natuke lähemalt korrekt
Õpetaja: nii. Ja. Nüüd kui vajutad entrid siis, ta nagu minna tagasi Näiteks et Aa. Ei, ma midagi valesti. Tegin mida iganes. Nüüd, kui vajad entrit, siis so beat. Näete. Real Nelikümmend viis. Kas on seda Sama meetodit juba näha.
Õpetaja: Returnis on see sama lause, mis me selekteerisime. This user. Name ei ole tühi ja and this password ei ole Tühi on nii?
Õpetaja: Ta teeb sellest meetodi, kui me võtame nüüd entrit. Nüüd ta fikseeris selle ära. Aga nüüd on lihtsalt see, et see Meetod nagu elab teisel kukil niimoodi väga halvasti.
Õpetaja: Siis lihtsalt tuleb lüüa. Natuke nüüd üksteisega lahku.
Õpetaja: Kas näete seda?
Õpetaja: Ainuke asi, mis nüüd korraks võib teha, on see. Et Paneme korra need mõlemad meetodid niimoodi kokku.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd järjestuse mõttes oleks mõnusam nagu jaavas. Mul on peameetod, mis Hakkab kutsuma välja alammeetodeid raamatud. Kuidas me loeme, Kas alt ülesse või ülevalt alla,
Õpetaja: Kui me loeme raamatus lehekülge
Õpetaja: ülevalt alla, tahaks lugeda neid asju samamoodi, et ma ei taha näha seda asja. Ma tahan kõigepealt näha seda asja. Sest siin võib teha niimoodi, et tõmbate need kokku, on hea ka. Vaata, Tulete siia selle rea peale. Te võtate kõik need read kontrolliks.
Õpetaja: Tulete siia alla Control B ja nüüd nad on oma järjekorra ära vahetanud. Kas saate aru, mis me tegime?
Õpetaja: Sest et nüüd on niimoodi, Kui seda lahti teha, vaata seda neid meetodeid, meil on login, meetod,
Õpetaja: sõnum, Els. Viska teada vea teade. Kas see nüüd hakkab nagu klappima? Viska viga, ma panen siia lihtsalt, et oleks, midagi ees.
Õpetaja: Nii on nii?
Õpetaja: Selle viimase asja siit üldse. Selle võib ära kustutada. Meil ei ole seda tegelikult vaja. Meil on nüüd kaks meetodit, Meil on meetod ja meil on Nüüd saate aru, et kas seda ifi on natukene mõnusam lugeda, kui oli ennem see jama seal sees,
Õpetaja: On ju tegelikult koodi? Loetavus Paranes, aga võib öelda seda, et üks meetod tuli juurde koodiliidu tuli juurde.
Õpetaja: Kui hakatakse midagi jahuma, vaata siis Ta võibolla ütleks, et. Noh, aga sul ei ole vaja seda. Vaata, et see see If oli tegelikult ka piisavalt ee, lihtsalt toetav või Mida iganes, onju. Aga mina nagu vaidleksin vastu. Mina näiteks tahaks niimoodi näha seda. Ma ei taha näha mingisugust If ide sees võrdlusi,
Õpetaja: mina ei soovi, sest et see, peameetod. See peab hakkama rääkima minuga. Story Jah
Õpetaja: võtsa korra vaadata. Mul ei lase siin. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, kuna ta Ütleb lihtsalt, ta kohe ütleb, et ee, on õige.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et sul on ees see tekst. Vaata, kuhu pood on katki jäänud puuduta. Ära see. Pane see. Puuta see ära.
Õpetaja: Usute see ka siit ära.
Õpetaja: Ja see ütleb, et sul Ipl see blokk on ka katki. Vaata, et Siin on. Midagi ka oli ka
Õpetaja: ei saa. Aa, vaata, ma näitan. Vaatame, näitan kohe, mis sul jääda on.
Õpetaja: Vaata, If lause ulatuses osa sulgude vahel. Sinu If Lause saab siin otsa. Siin ta oodab. Ootab hoopis sulge see et sa panid niimoodi, või noh kuidas iganes sattusid Need sulud sulle siin.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tuleb ära võtta sellepärast, et see ei ole õige süntaks. Ja ta ei saa nagu niukest koodi ekstraktida, mis On nagu süntaksi mõttes katki. M,
Õpetaja: ma vaatan korra. Siin on ka veel midagi. Siis
Õpetaja: ma ei tea, Tule järgi Lihtsalt Jah, enda failidel, Kes tahab tulla järgi, siis ma teen selle come ära.
Õpetaja: Lausa
Õpetaja: ma sellegi poolest. Pakun võimaluse. Kas keegi tahab järgi tulla või ei taha? Ei, siis ma teen ära praegult teie roll Backiga Või kustutage ära. Plats puhtaks all Peab vaatama Niukene haigutama. Niukene, tühjus,
Õpetaja: Kui on, siis Te olete valmis Nüüd te võite teha.
Õpetaja: Otsite selle? Õpetaja Feb seitse haru New Branch
Õpetaja: peale. Fetch i Loomulikult New Bradge Pange mingi oma nimi.
Õpetaja: Mingi seitse. Sidekriips, B, kaks, V, kolm, V, neli, Tulgu Need harusid. Järsku kümme. Tee. Sinna peaasi. Ruttu tulete. Järgi see. On kõige Tähtsam. Tulge ruttu järgi.
Õpetaja: Ee, sellepärast hakkabki natuke toimuma see. Vaata, et kuskil nagu koht läheb katki. Jah, maailma saab vaadata, aga ma tegelikult Oleks tahtnud vältida seda, et minna nagu kellegi arvuti taha vaatama.
Õpetaja: Kui tahate, et hiljem nagu uurida, mis valesti on, ja nii edasi, siis Selle asemel lihtsalt tehke üks kiire kommit.
Õpetaja: Sest see ja see haru jääb teil alles,
Õpetaja: et kui mittige ära ja siis saab pärast uurida, Vaata, vaadata, nagu arutada kas Cloudiga, Et mis mul siin valesti oli, Et Miks mul punane on või Miks mul midagi toimida teha Ee, Mis seal oli, ka? Mis koha annab Märku on See et punased jooned ja kui üleval vaadata seda,
Õpetaja: et on siin see punane ümmargune Ring ütleb, et mingi üks error või kaks error. Kui sütaks on katki, siis on nagu see asi, nagu on halvasti.
Õpetaja: Ee, et praegult even Ei, saanudki tegelikult lihtsalt, ee, ekstraktida seda meetodit. Sellepärast see kood oli nagu süntaksi mõttes katki ja enam ei osanud seda asja nagu Ära hallata, vaata. Noh, kuidas see asi nagu peab toimima?
Õpetaja: Käsi püsti, kelle järgi peab veel ootama.
Õpetaja: Või võime edasi minna õppekavaga
Õpetaja: Räägime nii Ühesõnaga, nüüd on meil peameetod ja nüüd meil hak. Me tahamegi koodi niimoodi kirjutada. Me tahame seda, et see asi räägib meiega, kui raamat
Õpetaja: Inglise Keelne Raamat räägib meiega juttu.
Õpetaja: See ongi üks hea kood. Hea kood on nagu üks hea raamat, mida ta käest ära panna. Siis Tahad näha, et mis on nagu järgmiseks? Ja kuna meil on see tööriist olemas, et me saame väga mõnusalt hüpata, näiteks ma panen selle peitu ka siit, niimoodi, et ma ei näe praegu selle sisu.
Õpetaja: Kui ma hakkan seda vaatama, siis ma vaataksin seda selliselt, et meil on Patt on, käivitab meetodi. Kui ma tulen siia sisse, siis ma loengi. Kui kõik vormiväljad on korrektsed ja siis ma vaatan, siin on jälle Mingisugune meetod. Tee midagi teistel juhtudel. Tee midagi muud. Ma tahan seda näha.
Õpetaja: Mind ei huvita kuidas saadakse tulemusele, et kas kõik need vormiväljad on nii öelda Korrektselt täidetud.
Õpetaja: Kui seal on mingi pugi, et mingi asi ei tööta korrektselt, siis võibolla on täpselt see koht, mida ma Tahan vaadata. Aga minu luksus ongi see, et ma lähen vaatan seda asja siis, kui meil see huvitab.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma üldse koodi loen, Kui ma loen võõrast, koodi, siis siin on. Hästi, Niukene. Hea struktuur. Mida Tuleb teha? Loe kõigepealt iga meetod eraldi läbi, et tulen siia Vaatan loo kinni, siis vaatan, et siin on mingi meetod. Ma ei lähe sinna sisse.
Õpetaja: Ma ei lähe seda vaatama veel. Ma kõigepealt vaatan selle asja kuni lõpuni ära.
Õpetaja: Saan aru, mis siin öeld. Ma hakkan iga kord hakkan uuesti mõtlema, mis siin on. Ma keskendun selle meetodi nimel login, tegevus.
Õpetaja: Kui kõik väljad on täidetud, siis tee midagi muud, Mida, Mida iganes
Õpetaja: siis, kui ma olen selle nagu meetodi endale selgeks teinud ja saan sellest loogikast ära. Alles siis on mõtet minna nendesse alameetoditesse, juhul kui mind huvitab,
Õpetaja: aga ei tasu niimoodi lugeda koodi et Sul tuleb esimene meetod ette ja sa tahad kohe seda sisu näha. Vaata üks meetod korraga. Ära saa aru, mida ta sulle räägib ja Siis hakka minema sügavamale, sügavamale kihtidesse. Kui sul on huvi ja tahtmist ja soovi ja vajadust,
Õpetaja: kujutage ette Teil ongi värk, Vaata, kuskil midagi on valesti. Te peate lõpuks niikuinii nõudma õigesse kohta, Aga teid ei huvita kõik see ülejäänud plauss nagu detailideni teid ei huvita mismoodi teid ei huvita see, et siin tegelikult vaadatakse kahte välja. Username ei ole tühi ja päässult ei ole tühi.
Õpetaja: Teid ei huvita seda senikaua, kuni Te, kuni te lihtsalt. Nagu,
Õpetaja: Noh, huvitab sellel põhjusel, et seal on mingi pugi või midagi taolist,
Õpetaja: et ega teil ei ole, Ütleme, see ei ole niimoodi, et te liitute mingi uue projektiga. Hakkate tegema, et siis, nagu te teete mingit arendust, et te lähete mingi suvalistesse kohtadesse Ja hakkate vaatama mingit koodi. Vaata, et, oo, mis siin toimub? Päris äge ja. No noh, seda võib ka teha
Õpetaja: ei, sellepärast seda me Jaava mõttes kutsuksime ainult Private meetodiks. Ja selle selle. See tähendab seda, et tema ainult selles koodifailis sehkendab ja toimetab, et ta on ta on abistav meetod. Ta aitab meil praegult põhimõtteliselt lahendada seda Login meetodit ära, et ta jääb siia
Õpetaja: mõttes lihtsalt. Ta jääb nagu selleks et Kood oleks ilusam. Ta jääb sinna alla. Siis võib ta.
Õpetaja: Kas ta on üleval või all, siis tehniliselt savikama. Ma mõtlen, nagu päris jaavaskriptis, Järjekord on hästi tähtis Sellepärast, et. Ee. Ma räägin päris native kui me kirjutaksin lihtsalt puhast vaniljaavascripti ilma raamistiku abita, seal on järjekord tähtis Sellepärast, et vaata, sa ei saa. Jaavas Grip töötab niimoodi, et ta paneb ülevalt alla
Õpetaja: ja jooksul linnunenud. Tõlgendab Kui siin oleks viide, vaata, et. Kuule, jou, jou, jou, ee. Palun rehkenda mulle välja. Vaata siis, Tema peab eelnevalt see juba mälus olema. Päris hea. Miks ta nagu Vaikimisi paneb ta ülesse poole.
Õpetaja: Ongi päris vaniljaamas. See meetod ise. Peab olema üleval, pool, et Kui ta. Jõuab siia, siis ta juba teab selle sisu ja oskab seda toimetada, et siin on nagu. Vaata see, et kui ta on nagu allpool
Õpetaja: allpool seda meetodit, siis sa viitad Mingisugusele asjale, mida veel isegi ei ole olemas. Aga see siin on raamistik. See asi ise orgunnib ära. Et lõpptulemuses on kõik asjad nii Nagu vaja. Ei. Me ei taha mingit lihasmälu. Me tahame koodi loetavust.
Õpetaja: Meie lihasmälu on meil see, et me oskame Shortcut klõbistada,
Õpetaja: Ei, ee See peaks just see, Sest et jaavas on see nõue Public meetod. Asi, mida saab kuskilt mujalt käivitada,
Õpetaja: on alati üleval pool Vot. Ma Tean kohvimeši. Teeme kohvimassiini ära ka. Ee, Kohvimachiin.
Õpetaja: Ee, Tegin siin ka mingi aeg selle Ee, mingi aeg tagasi Minu meelest on päris päris Hea
Õpetaja: kohvimeši. Vaatame veits pilte ka.
Õpetaja: Meil on kohvi. Kohvimasin. Väga uhke.
Õpetaja: Kasutaja tahab vajutada. Aa, kett. Cappuccino vajutab nuppu. Ta Kui ta vajutab nuppu siis taustal. Siin kohvimasinas. Program by the way Jaava Võib kohvimasinas olla
Õpetaja: vabalt. No. Problem Aa Kasutaja käivitab. Vaadake. Public Asja tema. Saab nuppu vajutada. See võib olla nagu kood. Kutsub välja koodi. Vaata ühest failist teise. Vaata aga, see on nähtav meetod. Seda on võimalik käivitada Igalt poolt.
Õpetaja: Siin on see seotud selle nupuga kasutavaid pakett Cappuccino. Nüüd kujutame ette, mis hakkab toimuma.
Õpetaja: Kõigepealt. Meil on vaja teatud arv gramme Kohvihube Seda teate, onju? Esiteks, on vaja nüüd võtta, vaata onju? No mingi. Hoia mingit luuki lahti teatud sekundeid või on seal kaal, mis Iganes siis me näeme, et paremal pool on, kutsutakse välja Kett kohvi. Beans.
Õpetaja: See nüüd on abimeetod
Õpetaja: mis annab meile, et anna mulle kakskümmend grammi. Tema annab nii väga tore. Nüüd on, ee, et ole hea. Käivita, Vaata paremat poolt ennem jahvata need oad, mis siit ülevalt võtsime, Nüüd, ee, pulbriks. Kohvipulber.
Õpetaja: Siis on see, et võta. See on programmeeritud. Palun nüüd Sada viiskümmend milliliitrit. Ee, vett.
Õpetaja: Tundub natuke palju, aga Okei, Water Water on olemas. Nüüd on meetod. Miks Water ränd kohvi kaasa läheb? Water Rand. Kohvi kokku saamegi. Kohvi see On see objekt, mida Me tegelikult taga ajame kohvi, on ju? See siin oli public meetod
Õpetaja: selles klassis. Aa on see olemas. Need Meetodid on seal. Aa, abimeetodid. Neid saab taaskasutada. Ütleme niimoodi, et cappuccino L on kohvi piins. Kakskümmend grammi espresso L on kolmkümmend grammi. Ma ütlen, saate aru, Water, on Ma ei tea, mingi kolmkümmend milli või mis iganes see on.
Õpetaja: Nii. Lõpuks on see ainult Selle Selle cappuccino puhul on ka veel, see, et palun lisa. Ee, mingi meetod, mis seda teeb siis seal ja toimetab nagu. Palun väga, tagasta kohvi.
Õpetaja: Pomm Kohvi tuleb.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see on See mõte Public Meetod on tegelikult. Kas kasutaja saab käivitada lihtsalt ad miltfoome või getwater. Sada viiskümmend grammi. Need on kõik abimeetodid.
Õpetaja: Need aitavad, Need on ka koodis all olemas. Ja Jaavas. Nad ongi niimoodi. Et kõik public meetodid, mida on võimalik käivitada kuskilt mujalt on üleval ja Kõik private meetodid, mis on ainult ligipääsetavad selles koodifailis, et see meetod saab kutsuda välja seda seda, Kui mul oleks, mul siis ka, ee, meetod. Ja tema lihtsalt saab siis seal. Selles Getoamericano meetodis.
Õpetaja: Me Lihtsalt kutsume neid samu meetodeid välja vastavalt vajadusele vastavate sisenditega.
Õpetaja: Kas see ka Vastus su küsimusele see praegult, mis me tegime, on abimeetod
Õpetaja: ja ja koodi mõttes ongi mõnus, et meid ei huvita kogu see Helper staff tegelikult
Õpetaja: see olus silmapiirilt madalamal pool. Meid see ei, huvita. Aga iseenesest programm paneb ta alguses ülesse. Ma pean. Tegelikult. See on lihtsalt seda, Vaata, et kui me kasutame seda, intellige tööriista, Vaata, et ole hea. Tee meile sellest
Õpetaja: Aa selekteeritud koodilõigust eraldi meetod, siis ta topib selle Sinna ülesse Ma ei saa, mina. Ma. Ei ole viitsinud seda uurida. Kas seda või on kuskilt võimalik kontida, et ta Teeks seda, paneks Hoopis järgi. Vaata, ideaalis võiks see kohe nii olla.
Õpetaja: Ee, sellepärast, et tegelikult Jaavascriptis on niimoodi, et ta peaks lugema need abimeetodid ennem sisse,
Õpetaja: Ja Siis tuleb see, et on peameetod. Ja kui seda käivitatakse, vaata siis. Tal on need kandjad nagu mälus. Vaata aga, meil on raamistik, Mis Meie eest manageerib seda Panete tähele, et kogu see asi, see. Kogu meie funktsio funktsioonid on eraldi blokis. Methods.
Õpetaja: Voe ise toimetab siin Nende asjadega siin ei ole. Isegi siin on nagu programmiliselt. Nagu pigem. Kutsume meetoditeks. Tegelikult on ju jaavaskütus. On funktsioonid, mitte meetodid ja siin Ongi nagu see, et ta. See asi siin. Kõik on. Voe staff. Kõik see eksport Defalt on puhas. Voevärk
Õpetaja: siin kontekstis. See see lähenemine on meil,
Õpetaja: et see, mis on uus Komposition api. Seal ei ole üldse neid asju niimoodi sellisel kujul. Seal on kõik teistmoodi nagu kirjaviisis, vähemalt teistmoodi. Aga mulle õudsalt meeldib, see sest et seda on lihtne õpetada Õpilastele, kuhu ma pean midagi kirjutama.
Õpetaja: Tatablokki lähevad muutujad, metsotsblokki, lähevad meetodid ja tulevad siin muud asjad ka lihtne. Tead, kuhu midagi pead kirjutama?
Õpetaja: Nii, paneme edasi. See on hobimeetod. Väga hea,
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd Meil oli siin siis selles taskis öeldud, et ole hea Tee niimoodi, et kui.
Õpetaja: Kui aga ei ole nagu kõike täidetud, siis ee, palun
Õpetaja: kuva seda teadet. Täida kõik väljad
Õpetaja: selle jaoks. Loo. Eraldi komponentanger, mis võtab sisse Message Props what is this guy talking about. No kohe hakkame vaatama. Nii, teeme seda kõigepealt. Step by Step. Ee, Võtame lihtsalt praegult Ee, lahti
Õpetaja: lahti peale. Ta läheb Seekord ei taha Greedi, vaid kirjuta oma alert Siin on ee, näidised ka simpel alert.
Õpetaja: Ilma nagu kinni panemiseta.
Õpetaja: Aa, siis tulevad siin mingi kinni panemisega ja ja nii edasi Ja nii edasi edasi tegelikult. Meid huvitab see, see kui taaskis on öeldud mingi Danger. Mis iganes me tahame seda punast.
Õpetaja: Ja mis osa me siit peame kopeerima
Õpetaja: ja vaata, mis see tegelikult on. Kui me hakkame vaatama, mis siin on. See on tavaline div.
Õpetaja: Siin on lihtsalt Class Alert ja Alert Danger.
Õpetaja: See on tema jaoks, et ta oskaks puteräpu, oskaks seda niimoodi kuvada ja toimetada.
Õpetaja: Meie võtame lihtsalt selle Dv.
Õpetaja: Vaadake nüüd, et te võtate korrektselt, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, tag I stagin i
Õpetaja: aa. Nüüd otsime koha siin. Kuhu me selle koha peaksime leidma, kui Me vaatame oma visuaali, Kus kohas ta peaks olema,
Õpetaja: peaks kõige üleval olema. Minu pakkumine on see, et tahaks hoida seda seda asja ühe Rohu peal, kasutajanimi, parool ja logi sisse. Need nupud.
Õpetaja: Aga hoiaksime selle nagu eraldi selle Alerdi Row eraldi, Siis minu mõte on see, et Vaadake rida kolm, kus meil on? Kogu see Row
Õpetaja: paneks selle korra kinni. Aitame iseennast. Vaata, paneme nagu asju eest, ära mida ei ole vaja vaadata. Isegi selle databloki võib näiteks panete eest ära panna,
Õpetaja: et tuleme. Otsime, et kui see on meil, nagu tahame siia ülesse teha Ühte uut road ja kolumnit juurde. Käsitsi teeme.
Õpetaja: Tuleme siia, intri Div ja Tab ja Enter ja Tab ja Enter.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd me kavatseme teha sellest välimisest teha ja sisemisest kolumni ja siia sisse. Paneme selle Alerdi. Olete nõus,
Õpetaja: et tuleks niuke struktuur Lõgendrit. Ka. No mälus on Veel endiselt see copy. Vaata sellest eelmisest kohast. Aga ärme seda pesti veel. Teeme selle valmis siia. Ütleme. Et. Kuule, sina anna mulle stiili mõttes
Õpetaja: võime kohe panna selle Justify Content Center ka ära, et kõik on nagu keskel
Õpetaja: ja sinule. Ütleme, et sina ole class.
Õpetaja: Ee, kolm
Õpetaja: Ja kohe vaatame. Kolm pikkust ka. Vaata, kohe, nagu tegeleme ühe asjaga veel. Millega me veel ei ole tegelenud ja nüüd võib siia korra entrid lüüa niimoodi, et. Noh, las ta korra praegult olla. Siis niimoodi siin. Kurat, ta pani kohe. Vaata, sõi ära. Need, aga et umbes niimoodi. Et Kas nüüd on Niukene asi, et meil on üks uus ohu juures. Üks uus kolumn juures
Õpetaja: Ja siin Kolumni sees on Alert
Õpetaja: Aa, Simple Danger Alert Check out.
Õpetaja: Ma panen selle korra siia kõrvale. Ma teen natukene väiksemaks Saada niimoodi,
Õpetaja: aga ta samal ajal tahaks. Noh, Vabandust, ma panen selle siia ette. Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Meie mõte on nagu, et tuleks midagi niisugust.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: väga hea, ma nüüd korra. Kas ma võin suure ekraanile panna. Siin midagi keerulist pole. Sealt tuleb särgi ka tulla. Vaata, nüüd on see, et kell kaksteist pidime lõuna tegema, Onju. Keegi soovis, et oleks kindel. Fix time.
Õpetaja: Ee, et nüüd, kui me seda vaatame korra, kui ma teen selle suureks, siis mis probleem siin on?
Õpetaja: Aa, kumab. Kohe edasi.
Õpetaja: Ta kuvab nagu väga laias ulatuses. Nagu see kastikene. Nagu päris. Nii vist ikka. Ei tahaks Onju
Õpetaja: nüüd, mis siin tuleb mängu, on see
Õpetaja: on see, et me saame kolumnitele öelda, et mis on nagu nende laius ja jälle sisse ehitatud funktsionaalsus, nüüd kogu See osa, mis te praegult näete,
Õpetaja: Kujutage, et selle kogu laiuse. Kui jagaks selle võrdseks osaks, siis see kogu tervik praegult moodustab numbri kaksteist Kogu laius siin selles kontekstis praegult.
Õpetaja: Kui ta oleks juba kuskil juba. Kui ta oleks. Kui ta oleks ainult pool sellest, siis see on ikka praegult. Kogu laius on kaksteist.
Õpetaja: Nii lihtsalt tean. See on see asi. See on tehnoloogia.
Õpetaja: See kogu laius igal juhul, mis iganes laius sa praegu ekraanil näed? Vaikimisi on kogu laius ja see on. Mõtteliselt saab selle jagada kaheteistkümneks osaks,
Õpetaja: Kui mina tahaksin näiteks, et oleks poole Väiksem või isegi veel rohkem, siis. Noh, alustame poole väiksemast, kui ma tuleks nüüd siia sellesse samasse kolumnisse, mille sees see alert on,
Õpetaja: et Ma olen öelnud ära, et see tiv Kogu Tiff on kolm ja tulen siia klassi. Panen tühik ja kirjutan kolm sidekriips. Siis näete, pakub numbreid kuni kaheteistkümneni. On. Nii Kolm kuus oleks see, et ma tahaksin jagada seda kogu maksimum osa mõtteliselt niiöelda pooleks,
Õpetaja: kui ma panen siia Kolm, kuus ja tulen vaatan, läheks poole väiksemaks,
Õpetaja: kui ma panen sellest. Ee, kolm, kolm. Noh, See on siis põhimõtteliselt. Aa, neljandik, onju Ja Kolmandik, neljandik. Kaksteist on, saate aru? Läks kohe väiksemaks.
Õpetaja: Ei, no nii ja naa. No ma panen praegult. Ma ütlen, pikseid me taga ei aja. Ma panen ta lihtsalt praegult niimoodi. Aga oma töödest? Te saate loomulikult seda manageerida. Meil nüüd tuli üks uus tööriist juurde.
Õpetaja: Ee, Bootrapil on mingi tiim määratud kolliks, Siis ta Siis ta käitub, kui kolumb.
Õpetaja: Aga me saame anda temale mõttelist laiust. Mis mõttelist? Sellepärast ma ei taha pikslitega seda paika panna kui ma paneks praegu siin, et pane nagu mingi kakssada pikslit. Siin tundub väga Timm. Noh, siis tuleb mingi Juku, kes teeb seal oma mobiilis lahti. Ja siis tal on mingi üli tuksis. See asi. Vaata, kui see lärg tuleb, ette onju,
Õpetaja: et Me ei taha tegelikult üldse kuskilt pikseleid väga määrata. See on nagu erandlik asi. Me peaks kogu aeg tegelikult hoidma. No, siin on erinevad lahendused ja asjad, et nagu, et me saame nagu mõttelisi osasi kasutada, on see sisse ehitatud. Sellepärast see kriid on nagu väga hea niukene Lollikindel.
Õpetaja: Kui sa teed selle asja nagu enamvähem. Nagu ära, kasutad seal õigeid sätteid. Noh, seal on veel igast asju, kus teete mingeid tabeleid, Siis sa peaks natukene asju juurde panema, et saaks aru, et ta. Isegi kui sa mobiilis vaatad, et ära suru seda nagu erinevatel ridadel Ja nii edasi. Aga ta on suht hästi. Pigem suudab nagu manageerida ka mobiilivaadet
Õpetaja: nagu suht. Okeid saab hakkama küll
Õpetaja: Noh, võibolla ei ole Mingi maailma kõige parem, et käsitsi tees saab alati nagu mingi parema tulemuse. Aga ta töötab. Ja Reasonly Well,
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Ee, meil on siin sõnumas. Himpler Danger bla, Blabla on ju? Paneme lihtsalt siia praegu. Message,
Õpetaja: et siia tuleb meil message. Paneme lihtsalt nagu ja hea meelega paneme,
Õpetaja: Paneme natuke paremalt. Paneme ettenägelikult. Ee, Camel, Case ja Eron message.
Õpetaja: Kas on siin error messel Sees Okei, väga hea.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd, minu mõte on, See ee, et me tahaksime siis ju tegelikult ikkagi, et siia tuleb mingi sisuline tekst. Mitte error message.
Õpetaja: Aga kust me saame teada? Vaata, Aa, mida me tahame siia sisse panna, on põhimõtteliselt selles kohas siin.
Õpetaja: Et kui on mingisugune viga vaja, siis siin me teame, et See olukord on muidugi küsimus, et kuidas me saame põhimõtteliselt siit, nagu öelda. Vaata, et. Hei,
Õpetaja: Kuva, Ta ei taha, see on kaasa vaatamise Vaatamise koht. Kõik väljad.
Õpetaja: See on see missioon.
Õpetaja: Nüüd küsin mina teilt. Vaata, et mida me peaksime nüüd, tegema et seda olukorda ära lahendada, et kuva palerti Täida kõik väljad.
Õpetaja: Kuva alerti. Täida kõik välja mõtteid
Õpetaja: ühes kohas. Algul haigeid pärast. On haiged
Õpetaja: truu. Okei, aga okei teeme selle haidimise asja. Se. Seda lahendame ka siit ära. Aga ma nüüd räägin sellest sõnumist endast, nagu et ma tahan sinna öelda, täida kõik väljad.
Õpetaja: Kui nagu on kõik nagu õigesti täidetud, siis nagu sa saad
Õpetaja: sisse logida, siis tuleb see message vä.
Õpetaja: Ja siin on see, et Ma Panen natuke paremaks. Vaata, saadame back ile. Paneme Stop Light sõnumi.
Õpetaja: Kui kõik on korrektne, siis saadame sõnumi. Els, Ee, mitte viskaviga vaid Ütleme siis kuva
Õpetaja: kuva viga. Hei, kuva viga.
Õpetaja: Vea alert.
Õpetaja: Täida kõik väljad. Sööme missioon.
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele, et me programmiliselt tahame põhimõtteliselt nagu manipuleerida. Mida me näeme,
Õpetaja: siis? Mis on nüüd meie tööriist?
Õpetaja: Kuidas me saame seda teha?
Õpetaja: Küsin teie käest. Te kohe juba vastate.
Õpetaja: See aeg.
Õpetaja: Ei, Ei,
Õpetaja: ei, ei Sander, ei taha. Ei taha Id D idest. Tahame ära minna. Ei taha Id si. Just seda me ei taha teha. Me ei tahagi sind mäletan. Ma olen kogu aeg rääkinud teile seda, et
Õpetaja: meil on manipuleerim. Meil on vaja manipuleerida nagu mida me Näeme, mida me kuvame mida me räägime, siis me ei puuduta otse. Me programmiliselt ei hakka viitama visuaalile,
Õpetaja: vaid kuidas?
Õpetaja: Palun, bingo andmed, andmed On ju? Andmed? On see, mis meile nagu seda asja juhib.
Õpetaja: Noh, Et saaks siia mingisugused andmed, Mida me saame ka siin siis mudida? Noh, andmed, mis? Millele me kohe mõtleme,
Õpetaja: Mis on meile. Oota, ärge nüüd midagi pakkuge. Vaata, teeme nüüd jälle nüüd selle pildi lahti, nagu
Õpetaja: Meil, on see probleem.
Õpetaja: Siin Tahame midagi. Kuvada, aga Action käib all.
Õpetaja: Kes meil appi tõtab?
Õpetaja: Ei, meetod. Meil juba on login käivitad If, Vaatame asju, kes on meil. See suhtluslõli Data Blokk,
Õpetaja: Data bloki muutujad, sildikesed.
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja põhimõtteliselt teha visuaalis kuva Midagi, mida me otsustame Kuskil meetodi sees on ju nii?
Õpetaja: See on. Kogu aeg saab olema üks ja see sama vastus kogu aeg.
Õpetaja: See on meie suhtluskanal, need Kaks maailma, Need kaks blokki. Template Block
Õpetaja: ja metsadsplokk mängivad kokku läbi data
Õpetaja: üksteisega. Mängijad kokku. See on nende Connection. Jah, tehniliselt on võimalik siin ka niimoodi. Nagu Sander pakkus, et anname Id Id asemele. Tegelikult siis juba Rf. Aga me ei taha seda teha. Me ei taha seda teha. Me tahame, et asi töötab niimoodi. Nagu see oli disainitud. Kõik asjad, mida me kuvame, näitame ja teeme
Õpetaja: Nende Niiöelda reaktiivne käitumine toimub, põhineb ainult andmetel ja meie andmed on istuvad tatablokis. Seal istuvad meil muutujad. Kus taga. Meil siis päriselt on Mingid objektid ja sisu.
Õpetaja: No nii saime nüüd selle võrra targemaks, et midagi datablokiga peaks tegema.
Õpetaja: Mis mõtted on siin Dadablokis,
Õpetaja: Mis on meie mängumaa Data blokis praegu Muutujate mõttes.
Õpetaja: Lisame siia alla.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: meil on ju. Vastab ju tõele. Vaata, meil on siin vaja Nagu midagi. Kuvada siin. Ainukene moodus. Kuidas Vaatame ruttu seda inputigi veel uuesti. Vaata, on ju onju? Username oli siin seotud sellise asjaga, et see on see meie suhtluskanal kinni. Loomulikult, kohe eest.
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja siia tekitada suhtluskanalit. Siis meil on vaja siin ühte sildikest.
Õpetaja: Mõlemad pooled saavad selle sildikese communicate ja saavad seda sisu kätte. Mis seal sildi taga on? See on sildikeste defineerimine
Õpetaja: mõlemale poolele. Noh, palun mõelge lihtsalt sellele. Ma olen palju vaeva, näinud et neid kontseptsioone välja mõelda.
Õpetaja: Teeme uue sildi Iga kord, kui meil on mingi action vahet, pole Mis Suunas? Visuaal Tegevused, tegevused, Visuaal
Õpetaja: This is The Way Või communicate
Õpetaja: See. On see ühendav lüli see. On kogu see tehnoloogia mõte see. On see lahendus see. On see geniaalsus
Õpetaja: tublid. Käid.
Õpetaja: Paneme nimeks lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: No mis? Me paneme nimeks Airl Message sobib Error.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd siin on üks väga tähtis asi.
Õpetaja: Ee, et kuidas saab kasutada seda asja.
Õpetaja: Kuidas saab kasutada seda muutujat? Ma kohe selgitan,
Õpetaja: Kui me vaatame korra seda vana asja, Ma teen lahti siin. Me Kasutasime vee mudel
Õpetaja: ja siis kasutasime seda nagu atribuudi juures. Või mudel ja ot otse väärtusena, on nii
Õpetaja: kui me tahaks samasugust lähenemist teha, Siis Siin on üks probleem.
Õpetaja: Meie tekst ei ole atribuudina tag I
Õpetaja: sees, vaid ta on väärtusena tag I vahel.
Õpetaja: Saate aru, siin saab kasutada veemudelit. Näe vee mudel.
Õpetaja: Aga meie tekst, mida me tahame. Kuvada ju ei asu. Tag I sees,
Õpetaja: vaid ta on tagide vahel on Ka Samamoodi nagu teksti. Ee, Html element. Noh, see võib olla H. Üks või paragrahvi, mis iganes saate aru on ju?
Õpetaja: No ma teen Kõrvale Ruttu, paragrahv. Kui tahad mingeid teksti kirjutada, siis ta ju tekst on. Siin
Õpetaja: ei ole tag I sees on nii,
Õpetaja: Nüüd meie peame Natukene nüüd voed aitama, Sest et hetkel ta lihtsalt mis? Sest et meil on siin see error message olemas,
Õpetaja: Tema mõtleb, et sa tahadki Kirjutada siia lihtsalt tekst nii, nagu on.
Õpetaja: Nüüd meie peame nagu teda aitama. Ütlema, et. Kuule, voe,
Õpetaja: et tegelikult ikkagi mõtleme mitte siin ee, Lihtsalt stringi ja teksti error message. Vaid. Me mõtleme hoopis seda muutujat. Eks siis
Õpetaja: Aa, teksti.
Õpetaja: No
Õpetaja: ei, no, siia ei ole mõtet kirjutada, Aga ma võin ta korra ära täita. Vaata, saate aru, Error Message Tema jaoks on. Kas saate aru? See on siin lihtsalt. Aa,
Õpetaja: aa, Saate aru, Tema jaoks on see lihtsalt string. Mul peab olema võimalusi ometi lihtsalt kirjutada mingi label või mis iganes tekst, vaata, on ju, Aga nüüd me peame nagu aitama. Me tahame öelda, et me tahame tõesti hoopis error messilt sisu, aga saa aru, kallis, voe, et me ei mõtle enam seda kui stringina, Vaid me mõtleme seda kui
Õpetaja: muutuja nimena Sildike, me peame teda aitama.
Õpetaja: Ei, vaadake, kui te võtate selle Controllixini ära.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd lihtsalt. See on süntaks, mis? Te peate selgeks õppima, kui me oleme tag I sees vee mudel, mis iganes me Viitame otse sellele. Kui meil on kuskil, kus on võimalik teksti kirjutada, siis me peame aitama, et tagide vahel vahel olema Näete, vahel siin on üks
Õpetaja: siin. Ta algab nagu onju? Noh, on ju tagide vahel. Paneme natukene space siia vahele. Kui ei usu üks tag
Õpetaja: lõputu aeg, on nii, siis siin. Me peame lihtsalt andma märku,
Õpetaja: et me siin soovime kasutada hoopis mingit muutujat.
Õpetaja: Kui Nüüd, siia panna. Topelt loogelised sulud,
Õpetaja: Nüüd voe saab aru sellest, et me üritame siin enam mitte mingisugust ringi kirjutada,
Õpetaja: vaid me soovime hoopis mingit muutujat defineerida, kui panna praegu See kontrolühik
Õpetaja: juba. Ta pakub neid asju, mida ta näeb. Data blokis on nii,
Õpetaja: Kaasa arvatud see error Message on,
Õpetaja: kuna minul oli siin Vaikimisi pandud väärtus. Aa, siis tuleb see siia. Aa,
Õpetaja: enam ei kuvata. Siin lihtsalt Exterror Message
Õpetaja: vaid see asi. Siin on abivahend. Voele, Sa Mõtled muuta
Õpetaja: Tag I sees. Pole Seda vaja atribuutide juures,
Õpetaja: Sest et seal ta teab, et sa tahad vemudeli juures kasutada mingit muutujat, ta teab Sa juba. Kirjutasid talle ära selle hindi veemodel. Ta teab, et see saab seotud olla. Ainult tatabloki muutujaga. Seal pole vaja, aga siin Ma tahangi kirjutada. Võibolla ma tahangi kirjutada Terror message, aga ma ei taha seda kisu saada.
Õpetaja: Jah, näed, et niimoodi ta nüüd sinna tuleb, Nüüd, enne kui pausile lähen, ma teen komiti ka nüüd.
Õpetaja: Meie ei taha, et seal error messed midagi näitab.
Õpetaja: Meie tahame, et siis, kui On see olukord, et kõik väljad ei ole korrektselt täidetud. Siis näiteks täida kõik välja.
Õpetaja: Nüüd küsisin mina siin. Mis me siis siin Nüüd teeme, kui me teame, et ta kuvab seda. Mis on Error? Mssc S. Mis ma siia koodireana kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Pakkuge keegi.
Õpetaja: Keegi ütles. Diss, Ma Kuulsin vaikselt juba. Tiss. Miks ma Diss ütlen
Õpetaja: Jaa et ma tahan hakata Tatast midagi. Ee, nagu viitama, Kui ma panen punkti ära, ta Pakub juba siia mingeid muutuja nimesid, mis mulle võiks. Mis tahe võiks kirjutada? Veel e tähe error. Message
Õpetaja: Praegult on? Kujutage ette, ma katsun Praegult seda sildikest ma katsun. See on kaks varianti. Miks ma tahan teile katsuda? Kas ma tahan sealt lugeda andmeid
Õpetaja: või Ma tahan talle anda andmeid.
Õpetaja: Kui ma lihtsalt tahan lugeda andmeid, siis täpselt see praegult on. Anna mulle need andmed.
Õpetaja: Aga kui ma tahan talle anda uut väärtust, Mis ma nüüd edasi kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Kuidas antakse programmiliselt muutujatele väärtusi. Jaava või vahet pole, võrdub üks võrdusmärk.
Õpetaja: Palun anna uus sisu niimoodi,
Õpetaja: mis Me tahame talle siin öelda. No mul tekst on eest ära kadunud juba. Aga mis me tahame anda? See sisu.
Õpetaja: Ta ei taha kõik väljas. Ta ei taha kõik väljas. Andmetüübina on stringi. Me kirjutame
Õpetaja: üksik nendega. Vaata, onju, Et Lepime kokku, et kasutame neid üksikuid, kus saab Ta Ei, ta
Õpetaja: kõik väljad võite. Te võite vaadata koodi, aga vastab tõele. Et Error message. Algväärtus on tühistrering.
Õpetaja: Kui tuled siia algusesse, Siin Midagi pole,
Õpetaja: aga kui käivad, käivitad selle meetodi. Ta vaatab, et üks nendest on tühi. Juba siis ta põhimõtteliselt tuleb. Blokki täidab ära error Message I selle me staatiliselt kirjutatud tekstiga ja
Õpetaja: tuleb. On see loogiline.
Õpetaja: Nii Siinkohal tõmbame praegu joone alla Control Commit work. In See, kes tahab saab tulla vahetunnil järgi aga tulge siis tõesti Vahetunnil järgi. Vaata, pärast, alustame Siis nagu saame kohe. Kuidas oli ära tulemine. Mis need Sammud olid
Õpetaja: Rolback
Õpetaja: ja siis New Branch From ja mingi uus. Nimi. Nii kuidas tundus tegelikult. Mis te arvate, kas see või vanakooli programemine Kumb on mõnusam?
Õpetaja: Jah, Ee, te ei taha isegi teada, kuidas see kõik see Crap oleks seal nagu taustal. Nii, Stop Recording päeva esimene.